peu
[Musique]
11dans bas
[Applaudissements]
avenue sur le plateau de tout le monde
en parle l'émission qui donne envie de
payer la redevance avec nous ce soir
l'empathie sophie marceau
eddy mitchell
vince annulé
la crasse
adriana karembeu
quincy jones la fille de lino ventura
tina arena
the blind test consacré ce soir à
l'italie festival de cannes oblige les
messieurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le crès il
avant de recevoir mes premiers invités
je vous propose de regarder ensemble les
meilleurs moments de l'émission
précédente
ça s'appelle toujours tout le monde en a
parlé et c'est toujours préparé par
monsieur jean hugues noël
le manihoe vicieuse danse connaît
la comédie avec thor studio avec
tarcisio et cette affaire fait voir même
imaginer par exemple à vous êtes en
colère fait moi la fille en colère pour
voir enfin les attendait tant reste à se
concentrer ses l'actor studio pour que
ça vienne de l'intérieur c'est très très
difficile ça vient je me concentre aussi
d'accord nous arrêtent merlin peuple et
l'élection
donc noemi après ses cours à l'actor
studio vous rentrez en france et là vous
travaillez sur un studio où travaillent
également alain chabat et vous lui
prenais la tête en lui disant je vais
être absolument dans ton film c'est pas
la télé après euros les dernières
questions stomie est ce que c'est vrai
que vous avez donné un nom à votre sexe
voilà la gb
tommy commence pas quelle lettre du
buzzer darva dinosaures à peu près la
taille d'un dinosaure mais il en faut
consulter
capricorne dont vous êtes et a tendance
à tendance à avoir un réflexe de
fermeture par rapport au monde alors que
les gémeaux que vous êtes aussi dans son
contrat qui lui donne un côté et changer
mais on dit que les hommes aux sons ou à
mort marie qu'est ce que vous êtes
marie vous êtes mari oui c'est donc ok
donc donc changé lui arriver ça de
choisir le maîtresse de votre mari vous
c'est pas l'idée c'est dupont
monsieur donné beaucoup de mal pour
arriver à pondre un livre qui va faire
rêver mes lectrices parce que qu'est ce
qu'elles ont envie d'entendre c'est
parler d'amour
oui votre épouse et j'avais gardé de
nommer oui oui oui je pense pas qu'elle
va l'acheter tout de suite mais pourquoi
mais vous allez lui acheter non je ne
pense pas
s'ils se tient si tu devrais plutôt me
donner ce qu'ils me annie l'année même
pas question c'était cette résidence et
dont ils ont fait pas retenu et
rothschild la grande théorie nadine
c'est que le vrai féminisme c'est de
mener les hommes par le bout du nez en
fait c'est ça le vrai bien entendu on a
tous les pouvoirs et c'est un euphémisme
c'est pas honnête tu penses
il change pas après les excuses et le
laisser l'histoire elle tirait le diable
par la queue
pourquoi là que le dire on doit apporter
quoi quand on va dîner chez les gens en
général on aurait des fleurs à carlton
est décédé mais sinon retour vient dîner
mais quand on a mangé chez moi ça rit
souvent j'en ai cinq ans aidé à me
lancer des amis alors nadine est ce
qu'on peut se soucier que sont pas
faussés s'est trompé vous vous êtes la
nouvelle fiancée de paul loup sulitzer
pour être tout à fait honnête vous avez
imposé à apple ou un délai assez long à
la 20 minute
non ça a duré entre votre première
rencontre est distendu s'est passé
combien de temps et va c'est quoi c'est
moi un mois avant qu'un mois pour la 10
landes de paris ouais mais on sent pas
excusez moi le chien peut écouter des
îles aucune peur vous est absolument
divine
ils ne voudront pas jamais voilà voilà
bien si vous êtes pour nadine taper sms
si vous êtes touré va d'ailleurs vous
êtes snobeck en vue de la mouillonne par
les élèves d'ulis strasberg institute
vous avez que noémie dit elle est aussi
belle et il n'y a pas longtemps l'a
appris à jouer nous imitent l'a vu tout
à l'heure quand mais l'affairé colère là
j'ai bien fait là quand nos amis à fait
la colère j'étais pétrifiée et moi à moi
j'étais seul coup on a le vip pass gold
de la nouvelle société qui s'appelle le
cancer club un bon c'est une maladie
qu'on pourrait me mais c'est une manie
comme ça hein
c'est une maladie comme ça après les
injections de cantegril mais c'est une
maladie comme ça ouais quand on a mal
ouais et ça fait mal
ah ouais alors oui quand on fait ça on a
pas mal ailleurs au courage sans public
et puis la lâcheté c'est dans les chutes
et maintenant
[Applaudissements]
voici du belge
m
[Applaudissements]
jimmy est ce que vous préférez votre
femme ou votre maîtresse c'est la
guitare n'est fait
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant jakl ans de plus
non ma prime un soir bonsoir mettez pas
à cannes car si j'y suis mais là je
voulais venir pour pourvoir ce film art
sophie marceau oui c'est vrai qu'elle
est rare en télésanté voilà je voulais
qu'elle joue dans mon film donc je suis
monté spécialement pour voir sophie
marceau est pas prêt quand je dis là
avec elle je me barre et je retourne à
cannes tu crois qu'elle va accepter de
jouer longtemps fait une sophie marceau
oui je pense que oui je pense qu'il
serait bien qu'elle accepte de jouer
dans mon film ce serait bien pour elle
ce serait bien pour sa carrière ce
serait bien pour il s'appelle comment on
fait les clefs de bagnole avant et
salaires
et maintenant
il y a
[Musique]
voici sophie marceau
[Applaudissements]
mason bonsoir
bonjour sophy merci nous vous connaissez
laurent oui on ces rencontres vous allez
jouer dans son film
ça y est je lui fasse en étant malade
c'est une bonne comédienne bien alors
sophie après juliette binoche l'année
dernière vous êtes cette année marraine
de l'opération photos de stars au profit
de reporter sans frontières avant d'en
parler je voulais rappeler à nos amis
téléspectateurs quelques chiffres
concernant la liberté de la presse dans
le monde en 2002 25 journalistes sont
morts dans l'exercice de leur métier
400 médias ont été censurés 121
journalistes étaient emprisonnés au 1er
janvier 2003 voilà c'est une étude qui
porte sur 156 pays qui a été publié le 3
mai à l'occasion de la 13e journée de la
liberté de la presse voilà donc c'est
quand même une situation extrêmement
grave
il ya un bouquin qui raconte tout ça
c'est le livre de reporter sans
frontières
[Musique]
alors se fit pourquoi avoir accepté la
proposition de robert ménard dette cette
année donc là la marraine de l'opération
reporter sans frontières photos de stars
je crois que ça se refuse pas quand il
est question de deux choses aussi aussi
simple que la liberté avant que ce soit
la liberté de la presse et la liberté de
l'individu c'est la liberté de
l'expression avant même que ce soit des
journalistes étaient des intellectuels
c'était des écrivains et c'est
inadmissible dans un monde qui se dit
être civilisé dans un monde où en plus
heureusement aujourd'hui on peut tout
voir et tout savoir enfin presque
on peut pas être indifférent à ça donc
il faut aider il faut en parler ça
s'arrange pas du tout parce que bon il
ya des régions comme ça comme l'asie du
sud-est comme l'amérique du sud qui sont
des régions où de toute éternité il ya
eu des journalistes malmenés par par le
pouvoir
mais maintenant on a vu des choses
dernièrement donc pendant la guerre
d'irak on a vu des chars américains qui
tirait sur l'hôtel palestine où étaient
des journalistes d'ailleurs beaucoup de
journalistes ont été ont été tués à
cette occasion il ya aussi les
révélations la semaine dernière ici de
christina à bordj essonne qui nous
racontait que aux états unis maintenant
il ya une telle pression du pouvoir
aider les compagnies que finalement on a
beaucoup de mal à faire du journalisme
d'investigation à temps attention à ceux
là je vois que vous tiré directement sur
sur les états unis c'est quand même un
pays aussi on a le droit de faire boeing
font colomba qui dénonce aussi un oeil
c'est un pays aussi de liberté où les
gens s'expriment c'est aussi cnn qui va
partout et qui parle de tout donc je
pense pas qu'on puisse mettre les états
unis dans le même camp que l'irak
justement où il ya des vrais charnier où
il ya vraiment des gens qui ont été tués
pour leurs opinions et pour dire les
choses quoi et aujourd'hui bon il n'y a
pas que l'irak on parle de l'irak mais
il ya cuba essentiellement
aujourd'hui encore et des acteurs qui
vont faire des photos avec fidel castro
et puis il ya des gens qui eux se font
enfermer parce qu'ils ont écrit une
ligne ou un poème quoi je vais attaquer
les états unis pour faire baisser mais
si on va jamais te proposer deux films
aux etats-unis peut-être que pour sophie
non je veux pas attaquer les états unis
comme sa bille en tête mais c'est vrai
que par exemple ce ne sont pas des gens
isma guantanamo il ya tout un tas de
gens dont on ne sait pas s'ils sont des
prisonniers de guerre des prisonniers de
droit commun on ne sait pas quel est
leur statut ils sont pas été jugé par un
tribunal ils sont enfermés je veux dire
tout ça c'est de la politique et de
toute façon la politique on le sait
c'est pas clair là on n'est pas bon on
n'est pas là pour parler de politique
on est là pour parler de gens qui se
font enfermer parce qu'ils disent des
choses parce qu'ils écrivent des choses
ils se font torturé et c'est
inadmissible et il faut le dénoncer
voilà il faut aider et c'est ce que fait
reporter sans frontières voilà alors
comment faire justement pour aider
reporter sans frontières va d'abord il
faut de l'argent je crois que c'est la
chose la plus importante parce que
reporters sans frontières s'occupe de
communiquer avec ces gens qu'ils sont
emprisonnés
et puis aussi il faut payer les avocats
il faut enfin je veux dire que c'est
beaucoup d'argent alors il ya des albums
photos qui sont publiés tout au long de
l'année on en fait la promotion ici dans
cette émission
toutes les semaines et puis une fois par
an il ya une opération qui s'appelle
photos de stars dont vous êtes donc la
marraine cette année alors on donne les
appareils à des ag stars qui font des
photos qui les font pas développer voilà
alors de laurent baffie la faire des
photos c'est joli c'est la levure et on
vend ses appareils il faut quand même
dire plus
compte sur moi non tu t'en forme et
emmanuelle béart
presque dix ans c'était pour la vente
aux enchères s'est parée du fric
c'était pour la liberté de la presse
donc ces appareils sont reliés aux
enchères ils sont vendus aux enchères
par exemple l'année dernière ils ont
récolté à peu près cent mille euros mais
ce qu'il faut dire surtout c'est que par
exemple à cuba ou ailleurs en iran en
birmanie si les familles ne donne pas à
manger à leurs l'eure l'eure l'eure leur
mari qui est enfermé ils ont rien à
manger et crèvent dans l'est dans les
prisons quoi c'est vraiment c'est fait
pour ça c'est fait aussi pour rapatrier
des familles dans les pays qui risque qu
elles aussi à leur tour de se faire
enfermer
c'est vraiment des des actions
ponctuelles qui est question de sauver
des gens de la mort quoi il est vraiment
question de vie ou de mort alors donc
ces appareils sont vendus aux enchères
l'année dernière vous aviez fait des
photos d'ailleurs votre appareil avait
été vendu extrêmement cher abandonne 1,1
y avait quoi sur ces photos j'avais
laurent te plaît
alors moi l'année dernière j'avais
acheté l'appareil photo de juliette
binoche cette année j'achèterai le vôtre
je sais toujours l'appareil de la
marraine jeter l'appareil photo de david
hamilton et c'était flou alors qu'ils
réclamaient dites moi vous allez me
faire quoi comme photo alors je sais pas
j l'ap
je ne sais pas pour m vers les enfants
pour les enfants c'est ça parce que
j'avais c'était plus que les miens c'est
un raison ces enfants en général et vous
savez qu'elle s'est jamais déclaré
sophie marceau le compliment que j'aime
entendre c'est pour ça que vous parlez
de vos enfants c'est que je suis une
bonne maman vous voulez qu'on dit ça
comme vous serez partie tout à l'heure
vous voulez qu'on dise que vous êtes une
bonne maman ce moment là je suis pas
dans l'exercice de mes fonctions
normalement mais un peu tes gosses qu'on
voit comment tu te démerdes
je fais tout ça ça vous surprendrai il
ya un autre compliments qui vous a été
adressé celui-ci par jean jacques
aillagon
le ministre de la culture le jour il
vous a décoré de la médaille d'officier
des arts et lettres donc en février il a
dit le ministre en parlant de sophie
marceau
il a dit c'est l'incarnation de la
liberté de la révolte tout net il était
fontenay il a dit en parlant de vous
vous êtes un modèle dans notre pays pour
nous donc français ans il est un modèle
pour nous et à l'étranger
vous incarnez l'image de la femme
française parfaite et vous méritez
sophie marceau sur le ministre qui parle
lui mérité pour cela sophie marceau la
gratitude de la république
à
non
c'est bien depuis qu'il ya sarkozy a
plus personne qui sifflent la
marseillaise
non en fait c'était un test vous avez
les fois les bleus 20 à saillé alors
c'est une ancienne j'ai toujours là tous
préféré des français parce que est ce
que vous êtes intéressés par l'actualité
par la semaine pour lui de vivre par
exemple avec l'histoire de la retraite
les grèves oui bah qui ne l'est pas on
est tous coincés dans nos voitures parce
que je me disais un truc à lui ce film
un seul a commencé à bosser à 14 ans 12
ans vous avez la venue perd quand même à
main dans pas longtemps de talent après
ses 14 ans 1
vous avez plus pour longtemps mais je
sais pas vous savez moi je suis un petit
mot un petit peu mal placé pour parler
tout ça parce que forcément on nous
attaque tout de suite quoi mais toi tu
fasses ont tous la retraite tu comptes
pathé point enfin tout ça c'est un petit
peu mal placé
ce qui n'empêche d'être citoyen et
d'avoir des autres en décider c'est sûr
quand vous étiez petit à l'époque que
vous habitiez gentil vous aviez beaucoup
de copains communiste et notamment le
père de jacques votre petite amie qui
vont des l'humanité dimanche matin c'est
vrai à l'époque vous avez été
sensibilisés par ça parce que j'étais
très en avance et déjà sensibilisés par
le par le racisme par l'intégration par
la condition ouvrière est ce que ça vous
a influencé ça on est et où on vivait
dans des cités où il y avait comme ça un
brassage de cultures de
qui forcément nous interpellait sur
beaucoup de choses quoi on était assez
au courant de ce qui se passe dans
l'actualité mais peut-être peut-être
moins qu'aujourd'hui par exemple parce
qu'on n'avait pas justement cette presse
qui qui qui va partout dans le monde et
il est important qu'ils aient toujours
c'est cette comparaison avec le reste du
monde savoir comment ça fonctionne
ailleurs pour parfois se dire finalement
c'est très bien chez nous un existant de
retraite et tout bon certes mais comment
vit le monde ça se passe comment
ailleurs et nous on était un peu on
était sur notre petit monde à nous
beaucoup plus qu'aujourd'hui les changes
paraît donc à l'époque vous appeliez
sophie maupu c'est juste avant la sortie
de la boum que alain poiré il vous a
donné une liste de nom d'avenue c'est
vrai il m'a dit voilà si ça peut t'aider
je te donne c'est un marron se fit de la
grande armée
sa fille kléber tout essayé puis
finalement regarder mais ça permettait
de garder
ils sont ainsi allés bien c'est pas des
oublis pas facilement alors davantage de
s'appeler sophie marceau c'est que le
jour où vous aurez une avenue vous le
savez déjà
bakaye à gombe comme ça il y aura pas
mal venu marceau l'inconvénient c'est
que beaucoup de gens croient vous êtes
la fille du mime marceau
ainsi quand vous faites ça oui vos
parents n'étaient pas contents quand
vous avez quitté le nom de l'opus s'est
énervé j'imagine un pearl away ces jolis
mots puis pourquoi d'après marc soir non
c'est juste pas de regret je dois leur
prendre maintenant quand on sait que
c'est le moment où l'amérique même
l'album ku marceau c'est pas facile à
dire non comment ils disent les
américains
heidi me dise pas la viande dans les
choses on va pas passer assure les
natifs dans les choses qui vous ont
énervé par exemple la chanson de julien
caire où il parle de vos seins ça vous
énerver non pas plus que ça
ces pseudos vieille histoire moi
j'écoutais je m'éclaire ce matin dans ma
voiture et donc je veux pas vous n'êtes
pas vrai vous ne voulez pas vous n'êtes
pas rancunière quand on vous a prêté une
liaison avec messier le patron de
vivendi ça vous a énervé oui parce que
j'étais enceinte
un autre homme que j'aime et sa mort est
très embêté qu'il y ait confusion
et puis et puis voilà j'aime pas qu'on
raconte des conneries c'est mon compte
donc ça m'énerve forcé mais ces
messieurs qui se vantait ses partisans
je ne dirai rien cette histoire
financière mélangez pas les sous je
venais page pour rappel sur les capable
de coucher qu'un petit gros ils nous
avaient dit qu'ils avaient non
mais quand il était venu mais si c'était
un peu ventée et avait dit qu'il avait
péché julia roberts et au lit je crois
qu il n a pas su bien sophie alors vous
avez eu des eaux vous avez eu débat vous
avez dit d'ailleurs on a tous notre sac
à mahler voilà donc on va faire une
interview 1 pén d'armes
[Musique]
ce oui ce que vous préférez en vous et
coût
je sais pas mais contradictions de
contradictions ce que vous haïssez en vo
mais contradiction avec physiquement non
ça c'est top secret ah bon ça veut dire
ce que j'aime pas en moins d'accord mais
ce que tu aimes
est ce que tu pourrais faire à ce que je
préfère mon nez tourner ce que vous
préférez dans le cinéma tourné ce que
vous détestez l'attend trois rivaux du
fatah et marc et sophie marceau ça non
mais j'aime bien les cubains je m'assois
sur les cas tu arrives à les mettre dans
l'ordre maintenant à baisser
je connais bien les la table des progrès
depuis la boum sur la première le film
vous jouez que vous préférez sophie en
fait en vérité en vérité je n'aime pas
trop me voir dans les films que j'ai
faits c'est marrant moi aussi
c'est bien je vais pas tout seul là
j'aime pas trop te vois on était
alors je ne savais pas lequel vous
préférez vous savez celui que vous
détestez comme dans tous les films que
vous avez fait une à birac vous haïssez
plus que tout je pense je bizarrement
alors que c'est un homme pour lequel
j'ai énormément d'admiration antonioni
mais j'ai pas du tout aimé le film que
je fais moi le plus grand moment de
votre vie
me réveiller chaque matin à cela s'est
bien trouvé ça le pire moment de votre
vie à part maintenant que le pire moment
de ma vie
l'option de genève n'était pas
formidable qui vous fait le plus rire ma
vie plein de choses
votre jeu il vous fait rien ouais c'est
comme ça que vous êtes signe c'est comme
ça que vous êtes vous dit tout non non
qu'est-ce qu'il a plus que george roy
hill a beaucoup de bien aux conditions
n'ont pas d'argent mais n'ont pas
d'argent c'est à sec
si vous fait le plus rire à la has qui
me fait le plus rire
je sais pas je vous dirais
tati jacques tati et a dû encore là bas
je m'habille porte à faux idéaux
glaciers non j'adore ce que fait de
mourir je sais pas j'ai envie de dire la
justice un peu ce que vous avez de plus
sexy en vous tous ces noms oui tout
c'est vrai enfin tout non
à
[Applaudissements]
m
c'est que vous avez 2 - section saladier
s'appelle mois plus tôt
c'est ce que vous regardez en premier
chez un homme bas à ses yeux c'est là
qu'on regarde et en dernier son dos
parce qu'il sent pas commis par le vient
ce que vous regardez en premier chez une
fille à bas seuil eux aussi moi je
regarde les gens les yeux nous vous
regardez en dernier c'est une fille sont
d'autres questions préférées quoi dans
l'amour le sexe à le sexe est dans le
sexe contre aix vous détestez alors
échangé la morgue les classes éclats la
vitrine de la roma va changer lorsque ce
que vous détestez dans l'amour quand il
s'en va
m
et maintenant
voici elie mitchell
[Applaudissements]
et démissionne bonsoir merci vous êtes
habillé comme moi ça me touche beaucoup
c'est vous qui a publié comme la part de
récuser moi tout ça ça va bien je
laissais sophie marceau oui l'actrice
préférée des français
ils ont bien raison et qui se préoccupe
donc de reporter sans frontières il faut
que vous fassiez des photos vous savez
et puis après on les vend aux enchères
oui enfin je suis pas douée d'un débat
fille coincée qui faisait faire des
photos alors vous êtes aussi rare en
télévision je dirais que ce film arceaux
merci d'avoir choisi tout le monde en
parle et pour parler de votre nouveau
disque
alors on parlait de décoration avec
sophie tout à l'heure elle a reçu une
médaille du ministre jean-jacques
aillagon vous baladez vous a proposé le
mérite mais vous l'avez refusé un
wip une légion d'honneur tous la légion
d'honneur aussi ouais et vous avez
refusé aussi oui non j'ai un côté
militaire moi qui me devrait préférer
les 10-14 edit ah oui je préfère ça
didier
oh
alors
et moi
les
chaque jour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
hors jeu
la pluie
ouais
ah oui
[Musique]
p
ça
il a lui même
[Applaudissements]
m
et moi davis jean de gaulle là
[Musique]
m
on peut
oh
ça
oh mais aussi d
[Musique]
nous sommes berra s'est achevée une
belle ville
houssam et racé
m
coli
ni m
après midi entre les mots
le haut
2 0
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors la dernière cerrutti 6 donc
extrait de votre nouvel album qui
s'appelle frenchy j'en connais aucune
donnée
[Musique]
bronchique 6,6 à orlando exige le clip
là
je sais
[Musique]
aux yeux
le temps
[Musique]
voilà eddy mitchell au monde 6
l'expert
homme qui s'appelle ben ghichir
sa double et mixte young se dit bien
c'est bien calvi et quelque 40 ans qu'on
en a marre et des mutuelles c'est
toujours aussi bien quoi sert à pissy
pas je vous en remercie normalement je
me sente bien et 150 entendu là bas si
elles vous plaisent c'est bien mais
monsieur connaissais pas mais comme
chacun sait pas les titres mais j'aime
bien d'artistes mais c'est vrai que dans
l'est ce qu'on a entendu au début
c'était pas très connu alors c'est un
album que vous avez fait 10 en
collaboration avec votre complice e
pierre papadiamandis voilà alors ce qui
est bizarre effectivement ces clichés
d'abord la musique et après vous faites
les paroles alors que d'habitude paraît
que c'est l'inversé
j'ai passé peut-être linverse parce que
nous on a toujours travaillé quand même
oui en fait au départ vous vouliez pas
écrire de texte en particulier vous avez
dit comment les textes qu'on m'apporte
été tellement mauvais que je me suis dit
c'est ce pour en faire autant quoi alors
donc si vous n'avez pas la musique vous
n'arrivez pas à partir quoi c c'est un
détonateur ça j'aime pas écrire donc ne
peut pas faire des rimes toile comme ça
avec des grands cheveux longs qu'il en
fait pas les petits poèmes que quelqu'un
mais ont eu du mal à endosser sa peau
est donc je sais pas faire aymeric les
paroles en fait non pas tellement
d'importance vous dites les gens
écoutent bob dylan depuis des années ils
savent pas ce qu'ils racontent et il
fera sa l'entraîneur pour le public
européen
non lui tend alors freine si vous l'avez
fait à los angeles vous dites je
travaille à los angeles parce que là-bas
au moins je suis sûrement merde et donc
de bosser c'est vrai nom mais parce que
c'est pas une vie qui me passionne mais
amusante enfin moi je ne les retrouve
pas ces c'est une rude 80 km à une des
pâtés de maisons à un océan glacial
des boîtes qui ferment à une heure du
matin enfin c'est pas très latin quoi
tout ça quand même donc vous connaissez
votre aux partages bas donc quand on y
est on y construit qu'on ne travaille
que ça va donc là je suis sûre d'elle au
studio à l'heure je suis sage je bouge
pas une oreille vous ai pas eu envie
vous seriez vous installer à los angeles
sont pas du tout ah bon c'est marrant
les françaises ont du mal quand même
avec la californie en de bien
fonctionner les 80 kilomètres tout droit
vous avez été choqué on parlait tout à
l'heure de la guerre d'irak vous avez
été choqué par la position de la france
pendant la guerre vous l'avez
approuvez-vous moi je l'approuvé gt
j'étais à los angeles d'ailleurs quand
cela s'est passé et j'ai appelé la
france pour avoir des nouvelles car aux
états unis c'était très très long ce cru
sous sous de gaulle en ce sens tu en 58
par l'anc ne sont plus tôt 6 2 c'est à
dire qu'il n'y avait vraiment pas
d'infos on vous attends rarement vous
exprimer là dessus vous dites disserter
sur l'état du monde au journal de 20
heures c'est pas mon truc
non c'est pas mon truc parce que je
crois que c'est réservé à des gens qui
doivent savoir de quoi il parle aussi
connaître c'est pas mon cas je suis
comme tout le monde j'ai la formation
qu'on me donne c'est ça vous choque
ce pouvoir qu'on donne aux saltimbanques
d'une façon générale à la télévision de
donner leur avis sur l'état du monde
c'est ce qu'ils sont qui s'empilent me
dérange c'est à dire que de dire ça
c'est bien ça c'est mal de disserter de
donner son avis son état d'âme sur des
choses que finalement qu'on ne reconnaît
pas assez je vais rejouer pour pour dire
que je sais pas moi tel tel pays vit
sous une dictature etc faut savoir quoi
en cause quand même mais bon je serais
incapable mois de jeu sera incapable de
dire ce qui se passait réellement en
irak avant la guerre vous la voulez il
fait beaucoup vous sophie ça non je
donne mon avis voire un ouais mais je
je pense qu'on est quand même un petit
peu au courant mais sans faire de
politique mais à partir des éléments et
des informations que nous avons tous
m'ont peut effectivement avoir un avis
sur wii sur les choses de ce monde quoi
vous vous le faites moi maintenant
non je ne fais pas moins non pas du tout
aller quand même
non ça c'est la manipulation de la
presse qui vous dit une fois un truc et
c'est repris 40 fois pendant trois ans
dix ans après dans les journaux après
c'est là où l'on contrôle plus très bien
et c'est là où c'est dangereux je vous
rejoins aussi un petit peu c'est que il
faut être aussi cohérent et une fois
qu'on se lance dans un débat il faut
aller au bout de ce débat il faut pas le
laisser tomber les trucs le drame dans
le métier c'est qu'on est très souvent
sollicités c'est très dur de dire non
quand on vous demande d'aider des
enfants malades ou deux mais après il
faut continuer coire et c'est difficile
d'être d'être comme ça voilà de
continuer bon vieux temps quand on verse
c'est vous aussi laurent voici pourtant
j'ai envie de vous demander quand même
là comme on a passé la semaine avec avec
les retraites et les gens dans la rue
pas de métro pas de rr patatras vous
vous connaissez bien le problème parce
que votre père était à la ratp votre
mère est écrit lyonnais vos frères et
vos soeurs est dite et tout ce qu'a dit
lyonnais finalement pourriez y être au
crédit lyonnais aujourd'hui si vous
n'avez pas fait de la peine que ça
devant la série d'accords non mais
sérieux vous en pensez-quoi parce que
vous toute votre famille était là non
vous êtes quand même bien placé pour en
parler je ne sais pas enfin petit
simplement qu' il ya quand même des gens
qui ont raison dans tout ça c'est que
j'ai pas les gens qui ont une vingtaine
d'années dans peu de temps
et puis qui vieilliront je vois pas
comment ils pourront toucher des
retraites
donc c'est vrai que c'est aux gens qui
sont là en ce moment de faire un effort
me semble vous vous dites on est un pays
formidable d'un point de vue social mais
parfois on se demande ce n'est pas un
peu trop assisté à horner ah bah oui
mais enfin c on a pris l'habitude
c'est bien et c'est irréversible ah bah
non les droits acquis sont acquis oui
allez dakar baptiste clément qui
conduisent les tgv pendant toujours la
retraite à 50 ans bas même si charmant
mais ils vont même essayé dans quelques
années plus tôt alors on connaît votre
amour du cinéma eddy mitchell vous à
dire bientôt réaliser votre premier film
qui cédant pardon vous n'êtes pas je
veux non j'ai pas eu l'argent en banque
c'est vrai ouais parce que enfin tf1
décidé que c'était enfin parce qu'il
faut bien trois rien ben voilà c'est
maintenant qu'il était si cher que ça
mondy tout magnon pourrais jamais le
passé à 20h30 c'est un film de d'adultes
donc c'est pas grave vous aimez quand
même le cinéma je vais toujours le
cinéma toujours refaire comme au cinéma
on va faire une machine à remonter le
temps et on va faire une interview
flash back
[Musique]
nous sommes en 1963 bonsoir eddy
mitchell heureux de recevoir soit un
jeune qui débute vous avez 21 ans
alors votre vraiment tout le monde croit
que c'est claude moine mais en fait le
vrai vrai nom s'est clos de lucien
moines à bord c'est un deuxième prénom
lui boucher sur eux alors qu'ils
faisaient surnommé schmoll parce qu'il
ya plusieurs versions
on dit que c'est vos copains du golf
drouot on dit aussi que c'est josette la
valise qui travaillent avec nous a dit
vianney josette ou que dont j'ai oublié
le nom qu'on appelait la valise pour des
raisons évidentes
pourquoi mais pourquoi on appelait les
rayons je vous dis toujours bête comme
une valise pour que joseph vallet mais
qu'ils sachent un jury dans lequel
s'étaient vengés map leurs jumeaux
échoppes qu'est devenu schmoll voilà et
c'est là que vous avez fait les les five
rocks au départ ça s'appelait pas du
tout les chaussettes noires
vous êtes fait avoir un jour vous
entendez votre disque à la radio et on
nous annonce comme les chaussettes
noires vous dites mais c'est pas nous
c'est les five rocks et en fait ces
chaussettes ce thème qui avait racheté
le groupe d'une certaine façon n'ont pas
acheté c'est un accord commercial entre
entre eddie barclay lucien le risque
était directeur de l'un des programmes
d'europe 1 à l'époque le groupe
ce thème est aujourd'hui donc eddy
mitchell vous commencer une carrière
solo voilà j'espère que ça va marcher
c'est oui croire qu'en maintenant ah bah
oui mais enfin c'est aussi à 21 ans j'y
crois pas ouais alors que vous étiez
petit et guy vous aviez les cheveux
longs à votre mère vous laisser pousser
les cheveux et dé xavier les cheveux
plus courts disant vous avez eu le plus
mince et sans questionner avec un tout
récent et ma mère nous cultivons
vous aviez toujours donc depuis votre
plus jeune âge les espèces de bananes
pensais jamais me j'ai eu beaucoup mieux
et vous allez la garder longtemps vous
pensez ben je sais pas j'ai encore
quelques années devant moi j'espérais
mais je sais pas je vous le souhaite
le blessé alors vous chantez beaucoup de
reprises de chansons américaines
eddy mitchell est ce que vous n'avez pas
envie de trouver un compositeur français
oui mais c'est un produit rare disant
oui vous pensez que vous ferez l'olympia
il dit j'aimerais bien vous n'êtes pas
impressionner par oui non oui aussi bien
sûr parce que c'est la seule salle à
paris où il y aura quoi votre avis après
les yéyés j'ai aimé yahia je pense c'est
ce qui s'est passé
comment comment vous imaginez l'an 2000
est ce que vous pensez qu'il y aura des
femmes à des voitures volantes des
trains sur coussin d'air
j'aimerais bien il des filles avec six
paires de seins thaïlande aux yeux enfin
les autres marron j'espère qu'on sera
encore là est ce que vous pensez qu'un
jour vous fêterez vos quarante ans de
carrière à la télévision ça se serait
formé à mais j'y crois pas donc s'il
voyait pas trop leur vote mais vous
comptez le garder ou non je voudrais
bien jours a bien changé mais paraît que
ça fait mal ça j'ai simplement vous
donner un conseil et dit je pense que
vous allez faire une grande carrière
personnellement c'est mais méfiez-vous
d'un truc vous avez une tête à avoir des
coliques néphrétiques hall
méfiez-vous des coliques néphrétiques
c'est bon vous savez lire dans les yeux
mais parce que normalement ça se voit
pas la mi mars
alors faites bien attention à vous et à
rien ce cinéma rice ah oui fataliste sur
varices aussi en vieillissant
en vieillissant manière aussi tu verra
plus tard
mais
6 10 6
c'est nous
[Musique]
michel
18 septembre au 5 octobre
mais non tout cela
eddy mitchell
sophie je vais vous laisser filer vous
occuper de votre petite fille photo bk
donc pour reporter sans frontières blier
pas vous est la marraine
toutes les stars ont accepté déjà
énormément de star a accepté de faire
des photos font pas si l'ancien vous
avez fait les derniers modèles un
appareil est ensuite donc ces appareils
photos non développés mais attendez
seront vendues aux enchères au profit de
reporter sans frontières pour défendre
la liberté de la presse
merci pour tout
et maintenant
voici ludivine sagnier
[Applaudissements]
il savait faire
la star du moment lady linn applaudi
comme une princesse ça va oui bien alors
vous avez déclaré à propos du tournage
de we femmes avoir appris beaucoup au
contact des stars avec lesquels vous
avez joué vous avez déclaré j'ai admiré
leur façon de gérer la promotion
désormais je fais des efforts je me lave
les cheveux pour aller aux avant
premières
ce soir il fait son offre ils sont bien
là ouais ouais sens bien alors cette
année donc le divine êtes la reine de la
croisette en inutile d'aller plus loin
c'est clair si petite princesse d'accord
vous allez monter les marches
une première fois pour le film de rose
ont un qui s'appelle semine poule et une
deuxième fois pour le film de 2000
heures donc ça fait deux fois
vous savez déjà comment vous allez vous
vous habillez vous ben oui les temps
alors je peux pas vous le dire à ce sera
notre grande surprise de ce jour là je
vois que vous savez quand même des
talons sérieux là c'est parce que je
savais que jadriya blaquart
les jambes qui lui arrive ici ma taille
c'est terrible j'étais habillé comment
on pourra les voir jacques chirac à
l'elysée le 28 avril était habillé
habiller jean ouais j'ai quelque chose
des simples de ça mais quand même quoi
bah oui ça n'arrive pas tous les jours
un nom du don alors donc jacques chirac
a reçu tous les acteurs tous les
réalisateurs qui sont à cannes voilà
qu'est ce qui vous a dit il mais il m'a
dit il m'a dit mais je vous connais bien
vous avez une notoriété qui est bien
assise et moi je dis mais vous savez
monsieur dans ce métier les chaises sont
plutôt bancale et il m'a répondu
rassurez-vous pas tant que dans le mien
non c'est vrai parfois et sierra contre
la raison jacques si tu sais pas quoi
faire le samedi soir je me remplacer
dati non mais c'est vrai vous le vous le
connaissez dit jacques chirac le
rencontrer oui je l'en quand on est un
geste de sart 2 à huy sympa ouais ouais
ouais
le cerveau est sympa dans la vie
beaucoup plus qu'on croit monsieur voilà
voilà
avec françois il se teint les cheveux ma
mère qui me demandent ni chef mitchell
c'est l'ami des stars c'est une star on
lui dit royal est troisième millénaire
c'est sur cette image droite le mieux
alors les divines la dernière fois que
je vous ai vu à la télé c'était aux
césars vous étiez nommé dans la
catégorie meilleur espoir féminin pour
votre rôle dans 8 femmes
et quand cécile de france l'a eue ce
césar vous avez oublié qu'il fallait
faire un beau sourire à ce moment là
comment ça se fait une fille comme vous
que vachement précisé toi c'est quoi
il faut pas la gueule quoi là j'ai fait
la gueule 30 secondes avant parce que
j'ai senti que je l'aurais pas ben ouais
c'est non mais c'est des moments on
contrôle pas ces mêmes vous pourtant
vous êtes quand même une fille mais qua
non mais je contrôle quand il s'agit
d'un personnage - s'agit de moi j'ai
droit d'être bouleversée je suis
bouleversé la whey cinq bonnes minutes
ouais ouais voilà
et alors après ces terribles parce que
les gens venez vous voir comme si vous
bougez était arrivé quelque chose de
très grave
parfois on al'impression justement qui
n'utilisent aggrave la situation alors
que c'est pas des situations très
importante finalement je me disais
comment il réagirait si j'avais un oeil
pas oui tu l'aurais à ce moment là tu
vois tu ne passerait pas saoul en tous
les cas le césar vous l'aurez l'année
prochaine pour votre rôle dans swimming
pool
à moins que cécile de france face à un
autre c'est bien ouais c'est vrai alors
donc tu es une poule c le nouveau film
de françois ozon avec qui vous avez déjà
fait huit femmes gouttes d'eau sur
pierres brûlantes alors je vais faire le
pitch de celui de poule vous faites tout
je fais mais en fait la vraie cible
je me demandais alors c'est une
romancière britannique interprété par
charlotte rampling qui est en panne
d'inspiration et elle se voit proposer
par son éditeur sa villa dans le dans le
lubéron elle y va et elle fait
connaissance de la fille de l'éditeur
interprété par ludivine sagnier et elle
nous avec elle une relation un petit peu
un petit peu troublante comme ça si
malgré le fait qu'elle n'ait aucun césar
est alors chaque soir ludivine donc
rentrer chez cette romancière
britannique un peu comme cela elle
rentre avec un nouvel amant donc que
vous êtes vraiment une folle du sexe un
totalement ma phobie m'bow quoi comme on
dit nous entre nous la la bimbo
[ __ ] on dit même une cagole le cas
gold voilà exactement le cas gold voilà
mais finalement mais finalement c'est
vous qui allez lui redonner
l'inspiration à cette romancière et puis
alors à la fin de l'histoire parce qu on
sait jamais simple et c'est toujours
bien l'agencé ap ap ap ap dit juste la
chute m'a même nom non mais c'est vrai
que la fin génial
je dirais pas non je vais pas le dire
maintenant je vais pas le dire bien plus
mais la jetée là là tout le monde se dit
c'est un peu je t'explique c'est un peu
comme le sixième sens tu sais il y avait
une espèce de femmes ça qu'il est mort
au début il est on le sait pas dans le
sixième sens où il est mort au début
pour les gens qui m il est mort moi
j'avais un copain comme ça qui a racheté
toutes les dernières pages des les
romans policiers pour que les gens comme
les gens qui les visent
c'est terrible moi je faisais les
fidèles attendent le cinéma je disais
qu'ils étaient là ça sent aussi se faire
lyncher c'est très bien ça voilà donc on
n'en dit pas plus 1 qu'est ce qu'on fait
dans ces cas là quand on a fait le pitch
on regarde la bande annonce c'est une
tradition manito diverses danses connu
[Musique]
quatre ans might want to cover froid
de hockey
[Musique]
tant pis
que les îles master méthode creuse
[Musique]
voilà si loin françois ozon avec sa
hotte remplie
vous savez que notre invité ce soir il
ya aussi un cd la bande originale du
film
[Musique]
alors osons il a compris un truc je
crois que par rapport aux autres jeunes
actrices tu de votre génération
il a compris que dès le départ
d'ailleurs vous étiez capable de rôle de
composition
oui c'est vrai je crois que je savais
pas moi même avant qu'il ne fasse
comprendre
ouais mais c'est parce qu'il m'a donné
la possibilité de le faire oui alors ici
vous jouez le rôle effectivement d'une
cagole d'une bimbo [ __ ] comment
trouver dont ahmed autres alors c'est
une fille qui provoque son s'en
apercevoir déjà quand elle rentre dans
une pièce elle elle est provocante avant
même de couvrir la bouche quoi oui elle
est odieusement sexuelle très agressive
d'autant plus que la personne qu'elle a
en face d'elle est vraiment une personne
l'antagoniste à savoir sarah morton que
vous avez vues dans la bande annonce une
anglaise rigide frustré
est cloîtré dans son imaginaire alors
que julie elle est dans l'action oui
clairement
alors c'était un gros boulot parce qu'au
départ vous n'êtes pas comme ça vous
d'info ouais non je n'ai vécu tout ce
que tu as dit avant non pas du tout en
fait vous êtes une fille vachement sage
lâchement normal un nom mais là il
s'agissait de traiter un caractère
excessif c'est bien traités on y croit
vraiment un
alors vous êtes un gros boulot avec un
coach à la production vous à payer un
coach pour faire quoi
ah non non pas non non non non non non
non non pas vrai du tout ça non non non
un coach pour faire du sport parce que
ludivine vous avez beaucoup beaucoup
maigri un oui bah c'est vrai que de
passer de de l'adolescente boudin dans 8
femmes à la bimbo bronzer dans ce moule
il y avait très peu de temps donc il a
fallu que je préfère les formes et
ensuite il a fallu regrossi à crolles
films de miller quoi qui est une
adaptation de la moit d'air ouais il ya
que trois semaines d'écart entre les
deux films donc il a fallu que je me
remette et que je me rafraîchissent
impôts parce que c'est la [ __ ] à la
mouette en trois semaines c'est ben ali
dans le métier d'actrice et ça
évidemment non mais justement c'est
certain temps même c'était agréable de
venir une [ __ ] ouais ouais
ce désir de dégradation qui a dans les
rangs le personnage est ce que ça vous a
excité
si bien sûr il ya un plaisir d'un
bandeau qui est vrai qui est très fort
mais c'est pas forcément les scènes
érotiques de ceux qui se trouvent
parfois ça c'est parfois on s'abandonne
et on se donne complètement dans un
dialogue qui peut paraître complètement
anodin pour les spectateurs mais où tout
d'un coup on annonce un truc de très
vrai mais les nouvelles comédienne elsa
sur les anciennes c'est qu'à un moment
que ça veut dire qu'ils assurent je
crois qu'ils sont beaucoup plus
travailleuse un hacker niort demain
la star academy je sais pas voilà ça
s'appelle féminine poule c 2 françois
ozon s'est présenté à cannes demain ça
sort le 21 mai avec charlotte rampling
et ludivine sagnier
[Musique]
et maintenant chez nous
lee
je
ça
qui
voici nos craintes
penser
soit rester
comme on va bernard très bien merci
il vous accompagne il est là sûrement
pas en avant il nous regarde
ah ouais d'accord vous allez dîner avec
lui après après l'émission
mais ça dépend de vous ça dépend à
quelle heure en terre dit oui mais après
il ya le tennis donc l'objet de terminer
toutes façons vous l'interviewer le soir
quand il rencontre à la maison parce que
bernard bonsoir
comment pourriez-vous nous décrire la
journée qui vient de se dérouler et puis
bernard pour qu'il pût expliqué à nos
amis qui nous regardent
pourquoi vous n'avez pas appeler à 15
heures comme prévu berna il est venu
quand même
aiguisant les couples qui est assez sûr
année au fond un oui à ce sujet le jeu
vous n'êtes pas comme ça va sûrement
tanon je fais pas ma femme ou mon mari à
la campagne avec heures je vois là mais
la différence qu'ici il sait que c'est
que nous la mission c'est que l'on est
marié
vous êtes toujours quand cuba n'ont
absoluement et fier de l'être
avec 10,4 ils me disent est dit est dit
et vous êtes toujours acquis merial oui
catherine j'ai connu muriel et aqua ya
travaillé avec muriel et dit un jour a
fait une pub pour cette agence de pub ou
istres avec muriel et voilà ils
embarquaient muriel c'est vrai voilà ils
sont toujours enfin christine c'est
c'est quoi votre surnom dans l'intimité
c'est la chanson la salle et c'est vrai
bien je dois dire chez
pour moi c'était dit qu'ils chantaient à
quelqu'un quand même il ya ça aussi
m
hélas
[Musique]
eh bien ça aussi c'est aussi connu il
est sympa dans la vie mais sympa quand
il pose le sac de riz il est sympa ah
oui oui très vous savez ça nourrit des
gens donc c'est tout moi je retiens pas
bon kevin dernière question puis après
on passera votre bouquin qui est
passionnant est ce que votre relation
avec bernard kouchner vous n 8
professionnellement jusqu'à ce soir par
trond giske asie sera pas très bien
alors à parler de votre book accès
extraordinaire jeudi le ghana pendant on
parle foot dames non non le radon anon
parent était gamins n'ont pourtant il
est plein de questions je sais je sais
mais bon en question ont maintenant si
vous savez comment vous êtes ensemble
22 22 c'est les noces de quoi
et doris vous publiez que si la crainte
chez fayard un livre qui s'appelle
françoise giroud une ambition française
[Musique]
oh
alors on connaît l'histoire de françoise
giroud enfants croit la connaître en
tous les cas conduire le cuivre c'était
un peu la reine françoise comme vous
avez été la reine christine c'était une
star
non seulement du journalisme mais
annonce paris ça a été beaucoup plus que
ça c'est véritablement un personnage qui
a bouleversé non seulement nos métiers
ouais mais la société française avant sa
mort kouchner jeu alors on connaît la
légende de françois giroux vous avez
voulu savoir ce qu'il y avait derrière
alors ce qu'il faut dire avant de
commencer c'est que françois giroux
avait plus ou moins accepté de répondre
à des questions auxquelles elle avait
toujours refusé de répondre à condition
que le livre soit publié après sa mort
oui ce qui s'est passé c'est que giroud
qui connaissait admirablement ce métier
était été et qui avait beaucoup écrit
sur elle même qui s'était beaucoup
raconté sont d'ailleurs ses plus beaux
livres étaient vers la fin de sa vie
obsédé à l'idée que quelqu'un allait se
saisir des sens qu'elle choisisse d'une
certaine manière est calé se retrouver
avec un bouquin dans lequel elle se
reconnaîtrait pas qui ne correspondrait
à rien ce qu'il avait véritablement
animé dans les mairies et donc son
éditeur claude durand le patron de
fayard qui a été son éditeur depuis des
années et elles m'ont demandé moi
j'étais à la fois très ému et terrifié
d'entreprendre un travail dont il était
clair qu'elle voulait absolument pas le
lit etc j ai travaillé pendant deux ans
donc j'ai eu des entretiens fantastique
avec elle sur toutes sortes de sujets
sur lesquels elle ne s'était jamais
exprimée elle a planifié son
hagiographie d'une certaine façon oui
sauf que là il agira là c'est ce qu'on
va dire voilà c'est ce qu'on retient
c'est que c'est évidemment pas une
hagiographie c'est ça qui est très
étonnant d'ailleurs parce que là vous
avez un petit peu franchi la ligne jaune
moi je suis ravi il ya deux sortes de
biens grains bien vous trempez votre
plume et moi c'est pas mon truc dans le
sucre dans la guimauve
la route et où étais tu mens auréole
vous déclenchez les grandes zones on
fait ça pour les petites gens ont fait
pas ça pour des êtres hors du commun qui
pourfendent leur ciel et qui encore une
fois laisse une trace et il n'y aurait
pas de pires injures à faire un giroud
que d'avoir fait précisément un livre
sucrées comme ça c'est pas le réclamer
quelques uns qui prétendent pourtant et
de ses amis alors qu'ils soient
meurtrissent c'est une chose mais qui se
trompe pas ce point sur elle ça ça me
sidère
alors commence aux origines naissance en
1916 à genève seconde fille de salies
gourdji et de l afld rajhi donc tous les
deux turcs juifs séfarades les identités
la turquie voilà le pèlerinage est
d'aller des journalistes la mère et
fille de médecin major colonel de
l'armée turque et les gourdji donc
choisissent la france comme terre
d'élection et à 20 ans elle s'appelle
france gourdji elle choisit de devenir
françoise giroud donc ça c'est très
intéressant parce que c'est l'idée de se
reconstruire à partir de ce moment là un
nouveau personnage et c'est andré gilles
ouaki vit toujours qui a 100 ans qui a
été la voix du général de gaulle à la
radio à londres et qui lui dit qu'il lui
fait faire une petite émission de radio
qui l'idée que tu es france bordjis
franchement ça passe pas appelez-vous
françoise un smash up et puis gucci
gucci giro a dit bon et à partir de ce
moment là il prend en fait elle est la
reine elle même avec un nouveau nom
alors son père à l'âge de 43 ans
disparaît elle n'a que 8 ans qu'on peut
dire c'est que son père n'avait pas
reconquis en france le prestige et
l'influencent auquel il aspirait et
quand il meurt la maison et transformées
en pensions de famille
il déménage ensuite dans un trou à rats
aux batignolles donc c'est vraiment une
enfance extrêmement difficile qu'elle
est extrêmement difficile et vécu en
plus comme une déchéance sociale
c'est-à-dire avec l'idée que il venait
d'un milieu où il était normal d'avoir
un piano à queue de manger des
côtelettes d'agneau et c est tout à coup
ils s'enfoncent dans la neige mais
préservé avec une dignité admirable par
la mère absolument rayonnante qui sera
le grand personnage de la vie de
françois cyr que sa mère veut quand même
en faire des départs fait française à
baptême catéchisme enfin elle veut
vraiment les les éduquer de façon à ce
qu'elle sait intègre au mieux les deux
soeurs et d'ailleurs quand sa soeur par
an contre concentration c'est pour faits
de résistance
alors là il ya l'histoire de la médaille
de la résistance évidemment donc cette
médaille de la résistance a été obtenue
par la soeur de françois giroux joe hahn
et un jour françois giroud c'est bien
plus tard ces années 70 elle se présente
à des élections et elle marque sur les
affiches médaillé de la résistance
et là il ya un tollé général de la part
d'anciens résistants qui disent qu'elle
a usurpé sa médaille de la résistance
il ya une polémique immense françoise
giroud est à la peau est à l'époque
ministre
ministre de valéry giscard d'estaing
président de la république et de jacques
chirac
déjà premier ministre donc il avait
raison quand il vous a fait cette
situation sur les chaises bancales et
donc
giroud à la demande de giscard se
présente aux élections dans le 15e
arrondissement de paris c'était la
première fois qu'ils avaient des
municipales à paris 1 et donc
effectivement elle fait état d'une
médaille de la résistance dont elle ne
peut pas prouver véritablement le la
véracité est alors ses adversaires de
l'époque s'empare de cette histoire avec
un férocité que vous imaginez ça donne
lieu à un de ces deux céréales polémique
qui va lui coûter non seulement la
défaite électorale
mais son renvoi du gouvernement ce
qu'elle va vivre évidemment avec une
amertume terrifiante en dix ans jusqu'au
bout qu'en fait elle aussi été médaillé
qu'elle avait par suit les papiers vous
en tous les cas ce qui conclut la sphère
d'une certaine façon c'est qu'henri
amouroux qui plusieurs fois intervient
dans votre livre comme un très bon
connaisseur bien c'était l'époque de la
résistance il dit à cette occasion il
confirme dix ans la tricherie la
tromperie et l'enlisement de françoise
giroud dans le monde songe c'est à dire
que oui mais encore une fois avec le
recul du temps tout ça est très facile à
simplifier et donc à juger tend à
montrer qu'ils aient été médaillés
comme le rappelait thierry c'était une
femme qui vient d'ailleurs et je trouve
qu'un moment où on s'interroge tellement
sur l'intégration en france c'est très
émouvant d'imaginer ce que pouvait
représenter la france pour cette
génération là qui était la génération de
nos grands parents
la france était la mère des arts de les
aider loisel qu'est ce qu'il ya de plus
français sauf une déclaration il ya
autre chose dans votre bouquin c'est
qu'elle publie une nouvelle dans un
journal de propagande nazie qui
s'appelle le pont voilà une fille qui a
22 23 ans personne n'a connaît en france
mais bon elle a été script au cinéma le
cinéma s'arrête à paris pendant la
guerre giroud pour gueye pour manger
qu'est-ce qu'elle fait les cris des
bleuets
des historiettes qui sont ensuite
reprises par des agences de presse qui
les distribuent à dieu sait qui et c'est
comme ça qu'on retrouve à vous confirmer
il dit que c'est pas grave non non c'est
pas enfin bon bref sont les moeurs d'une
certaine presse et il y avait des gens
très éminents qui sont devenus après de
grands enfants qu'on peut dire ce qu'on
veut dire quand même sans être méchant
c'est que ça a été une grande résistante
quoi n'attendez la fille elle a 22 ans
elle fait ce qu'elle peut dire sa soeur
est le langage et ses équipes abordables
et se dire ça justifie pas une médaille
quoi voilà non non vous savez on voit
aussi imaginer qu'il ya des gens qui ont
eu des médailles pour vous - encore tout
à fait tu te fais donc elle se marie à
après la guerre et le mec est foutu en
taule et sage imaginait pas françoise
giroud capable de faire ça elle prend le
train tous les vendredis soir pendant
trois ans pour aller voir son mec en
taule
oui parce qu'il est en prison près de
lille à la prison de loos et après le
clip
et après après le clip et l'avoir fait
libérer là elle rencontre son grand
amour jean-jacques servan-schreiber
alors ça pour les plus jeunes vous voyez
qui c'est jean-jacques servan-schreiber
c'était un mec du très très bon
il était magnifique île et hemani
jean-jacques servan-schreiber c'était à
la fois le créateur de l'express avec
françoise giroud et en même temps après
il il a fait de la politique alors
l'huile à 28 ans elle a 35 ans les plus
âgés que lui il a 7 ans de plus que lui
créé exprès et quand lui part en algérie
pour faire la guerre
elle devient la patronne de l'express au
moment où il s'en va non elle devient la
patron de l'express ce qui ne s'était
jamais vu voilà une femme qui vient du
journalisme 10 féminin et qui prend en
charge un journal politique et le on
n'imagine pas aujourd'hui ce qu est l
express de l'époque la télé n'existait
pas il ya qu une chaise c'est la voix de
la france et ça ira
il y avait un journal sur lequel se
précipitaient toute la classe politique
s'était l'express qui faisait l opinion
qui qui a qui a décrit la nouvelle vague
des 68 tout à fait et donc voilà cette
femme qui tout à coup dit à toute cette
bande de types qui la regardent leur
dire mais qui est cette petite bonne
femme et si elle croit qu'elle va nous
dire ce qu'il faut faire et dit à partir
de maintenant c'est moi qui vais faire
les liteaux
et alors non seulement en photo mais
elle va comment dire définir ce que doit
être l'édito les gens qui écrivent
aujourd'hui et nos grandes signatures se
sont tous d'une certaine manière
quel que soit leur âge d'ailleurs je
tire pas des enfants mes enfants tôt
sinon des élèves en tout cas des gens
pour qui elle a formidablement content
et donc effectivement françois giroux et
jean-jacques servan-schreiber c'est le
couple star de l'époque qui sont beaux
et gentils on voit les gens du pouvoir
ils sont riches y rayonne
ils font et défont les gouvernements
tout le monde vient enfin les élus
viennent dîner à l'express le soir de
bouclage c'est normal le plus court est
de paris encore une fois on n'imagine
pas ses fastes un peu comme cette
émission maintenant ce soir j'ose à
peine cette comparaison les voiles à
huile et marié lui les mariés sans
expérience riber avec madeleine chapsal
et au retour d'algérie donc jean-jacques
servan-schreiber veut un enfant
madeleine chapsal donc sa femme légitime
ne pouvait pas en avoir
françoise giroud à ce moment là une
grossesse extra-utérine sept ans de plus
que lui a pas bon il a ça se passe pas
il fait une dépression et rencontre une
gonzesse pardon il rencontre une femme
une dame qui s'appelle sabine de
fouquières il a choisi comme mère de ses
enfants et la girouette espèce de bonne
femme comme ça très solide qui tenait
comme vous venez de le dire toute cette
bande de mecs à l'express elle
s'effondre chagrin d'amour à la
malheureuse comme une chienne
ah oui mais c'est une passion c'est une
passion prix bhl c'est une passion
moi passions enfin je dis pas la peine
d'ajouter des objectifs que je sois là
donc tout à coup donc elle est là elle
écrit l entente bruit de l'allèle
reconnaît le bruit de la portière de
jean-jacques elle se précipita la
fenêtre et tout à coup elle se rend
compte qu'elle lequel le père à ce
moment là
jean-jacques servan-schreiber et sabine
de fouquet reçoivent des lettres
anonymes antisémites avec marc et ils
vous épouse pour avoir des enfants mais
des ja c'est juif sur terre enfin des
lettres extrêmement extrêmement violente
et on s'aperçoit que c'est elle qui les
écrit ça c'est une vraie révélation
mais vous savez c'est une histoire que
beaucoup de proches de françoise giroud
connaissait depuis depuis très longtemps
et bien évidemment quand vous faites une
biographie il faut aussi aller sur et là
sur les cicatrices les plaies sont les
sur les tiroirs fermé sur le terroir
secret et comme j'ai eu cette très
longue conversation avec françoise elle
nous en a parlé elle de ces lettres elle
ne les a pas nié
est ce que parce qu'elle avait du style
dans ces lettres parce que sinon ce sera
ici parfois par des tournures aimé
naître de démence à l'époque
servan-schreiber fit appel à des experts
graphologues à paris et à bruxelles
d'embrouillés il a eu la conviction que
c'était elle donc il lui a demandé de
quitter le journal
et elle a fait une tentative de suicide
il ya un truc extraordinaire aussi
d'angers l'histoire de son fils parce
qu'en 1940 elle se retrouve enceinte
elle essaie d'apporter comme on faisait
à l'époque sur les aiguilles à tricoter
et puis c'était vraiment vraiment pas
drôle
l'enfant reste on sait pas trop qui est
le père un jeu sud qui est le père mais
comme il avait choisi lui de enfin il
s'est beaucoup occupé de ce garçon mais
il ne l'a jamais reconnue et comme comme
il n'avait pas dit semble-t-il à sa
propre famille j'étais a jugé utile ses
planchers beaucoup à l'époque l'époque
était dans le cinéma là elle m'a parlé
beaucoup elle a écrit un peu d'ailleurs
qu'à l'époque peut-être plus
qu'aujourd'hui
sûrement pour les filles si vous vouliez
déclencher le moindre boudreau à moindre
ouais ça c'était quand même c'était le
droit de cuissage un mec qui était qui
était qui et et vilains qui était cruel
qui s'appelle luc assez vite je fais et
c'est vous qui dites à elle l'un des
grands producteurs est bien là son fils
ce fameux fils donc était pas arrivé à
faire passer en 40 se tue dans un
accident de ski en 72 quand elle est en
plein bouclage quand elle apprend la
nouvelle aile bronche pas giroud c'était
une femme qui se tenait c'est une
expression un peu vieux jeu mais qu'il
doit pas vous déplaire c'est à dire que
on se tient donc on se laisse pas aller
on se on se répand pas qu'on pleure pas
on pleurniche pas on s'apitoie pas mais
vers explain never complet est-ce que ça
m'est arrivé après c'est ça et donc elle
reste comme ça et puis aussi la
françoise giroud écrivain ce fameux
bouquin qui s'appelle le bon plaisir où
elle parle de la fille cachée d'un
président de la république et qu'elle
fait édité aux éditions mazarine alors
que son jules alex graal bosser chez
fayard donc elle aurait dû le faire
normalement édité chez fayard et elle
prend les éditions mazarine qui est une
espèce de messages comme ça subliminal
ça c'est génial
elle était courageuse là parce que moi
c'est un truc que la francis de
mitterand et mazarine c'est des choses
quand même qu'ils qui sont pas l'honneur
de la presse française qu avoir vécu
toutes ces années qu'il s'en emparer
n'est pour que l'on considère que l'on
pouvait transgresser quelque chose qui
reste assez protégé en france et
peut-être ne faut-il pas s'en plaindre
et qui s'appelle la vie privée ça vous
embête rêve ou qu'on puisse s'intéresser
à votre vie privée avec bernard bafouée
surtout à la télé un lit soir merci
alors été sauf à ce soir alors
incroyable avec cette françoise giroud
c'est que douze ans plus tard qu'en
match publie la révélation des photos de
mazarine priorisation de l'elysée
d'accord mais elle critique elle
critiquait le dis c'est pas bien elle
écrit à l'époque dans le journal du
dimanche qui appartient au même groupe
mais en plus elle dit oui c'est pas bien
sont pas des moeurs et caetera et donc
elle est virée
du journal du dimanche sûr qu'elle n'a
pas aimé ouais alors voilà en 98 elle
est nommée commandeur de la légion
d'honneur et dans son allocution elle
reparle
de la médaille de la résistance usurpée
et en profite pour en remettre une
couche et dit que ce ne sont que des
calomnies que jusqu'au dernier moment
s'est battu elle nie jusqu'au dernier
moment ce extraordinaire 3g touchant
c'est touchant mais c'est très touchant
et c'est en même temps cette espèce
d'acharnement à à suivre son chemin et
surtout à apparaître tel qu'elle veut
l'être
ouais et christine est-ce qu'elle a
failli parce qu'on se convaincre elle
même à la fin ce qui les croyaient elle
même c'est très possible
est-ce que c'est pas un peu tôt
christine sérieux là la tombée à peine
refermée la non et comment peut-on dire
ça voilà quelqu'un qui avait demandé que
j'entreprenais ce travail il ya deux ans
donc de gens de d'entretien de
conversation de rencontre et cetera 1
et donc voilà
le patron de fayard qui était aussi son
éditeur a jugé qu'il fallait terminer ce
livre pour un suis efforcé de faire ça à
faire à ce qu'on a à votre bouquin dans
le scandale ce serait de ne pas rendre à
cette femme ce qu'elle a toujours
revendiqué
c'est à dire la liberté la façon
d'assumer sa vie et bien évidemment si
elle me demandait de l'écrire c'est
qu'elle pensait probablement est-ce
qu'elle pensait que je devais parler des
lettres anonymes par exemple je crois
que le plus bel hommage qu'on puisse lui
rendre c'est de décrire une vie en clair
obscur un toutes les vies simplement
avec son talent sa forme et cette
extraordinaire contribution qui a été la
sienne ce pays
[Musique]
or christine vous êtes une excellente
intervieweuse je vous vois tous les tous
les dimanches soirs en rentrant normes
anti je vous regarde c'est un moment
comme ça je regarde votre émission sur
france 3 ça causait de vous endormir du
pas du tout non ça m'endort pas du tout
non je trouve ça très bien alors vous
allez faire les questions
et oui vous êtes interne meuse on va
faire la non interview ici nos craintes
qu'elle question devrais-je vous poser
pour vous me trouviez chiant que vous
m'interrogez sur tout sauf sur mon livre
mouais pour vous me trouviez méchant moi
j'arrive pas à vous trouver méchant je
vous trouve vif vindicatif
un peu condescendant est temps de vous
en mettront parfois pas vraiment méchant
donc là j'ai du mal
christine quelle question devrait je
vous posais pour prendre une gifle que
vous attaquez à la famille ta mère par
exemple
quelle question devrait je vous posais
pour qu'on devienne amis que vous
arrêtiez de m'en pose et que moi je ne
vous en pose pas non plus d'accord
contre regarde et qu'on éclate de rire
quelle question devrait je vous posais
pour vous me répondiez par un mensonge
sympa dans la vie combien d'âmes en avez
vous voilà quelle question devrait je
vous posais pour vous faire rougir mes
mensurations enfin un truc comme ça vous
avez des gros nichons
quelle question devrait je vous posais
pour terminer cette interview en beauté
que si quand est-ce qu'on se voit à
ben najah beaucoup de collègues
étrangers ici notre oeuvre
j'ai des vies
ça va être en quarts
et maintenant oui comme novell novell
m
le 6 avril en attendent
[Applaudissements]
il
waouh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous connaissez adriana est dit non mais
je suis ravi c'est ce qu'on prend
beaucoup d'immeubles pour dire les
grandes noms mais grande elle a un peu
grand ça va briller m'a alors sophie
marceau est la marraine de l'opération
photos de stars au profit de reporter
sans frontières david douillet c'est les
pièces jaunes david douillet c'est les
pièces jaunes avec bernie effectivement
et vous donc que vous êtes la marraine
de la croix-rouge c'est pas nouveau déjà
ça fait plusieurs années que ça dure
alors cette année c'est la campagne être
solidaire c'est un don un moniteur
d'isère
[Musique]
ce samedi 17 et dimanche les humains
c'est la quête nationale de la croix
mais s'il ya triana n'est pas là c'est
robert qui s'en chargera ou bernard
gisèle une charge
ouais ben j'espère que vous avez
beaucoup donné aujourd'hui pour la croix
rouge
même si c'était pas adriana karembeu
évidemment et demain nous pouvons encore
donné demain dimanche 18 voilà il ya 27
mille bénévoles qui quêtent dans la rue
donc vous vous aller quêter exactement
quel feu pour pas être déçu si je sais
pas si je peux faire je peux faire ouais
je peux dire bah oui je serai à car il
ya déjà beaucoup d'entre eux sera calme
oui assure la croisette
je crois que vais y avait moi ouais moi
aussi je n'en voulais pas y aller un
pilar d'incohérent les jaunes on va
donner pour la croix rouge
c'est génial ce que vous faites pour la
croix rouge massé et c'est avec plaisir
vraiment à tout ce qui me demandent la
croix rouge je suis prête à prête à
faire oui le bouche à bouche est tout
ouïe pour des raisons sanitaires
évidemment
c'est bien c'est pas trop dur mais pas
mes policiers pour animer la personne
non mais pas la langue que ça peut
ranimer la personne en même temps qu'est
ce que tu fais les appareils photos oui
vous savez quand on fait des puits vous
pensez bien oui on fait ça sans arrêt
nous aussi vous aurez des grands [ __ ]
roi voilà christine aubrey faire des
photos il ya les liens des écoutes et
c'est formidable raconte non c'est pas
ça c'est que maintenant on va parler de
moi pas d'être christian il va comme en
question et si oui avec une discrétion
comme si vous le connaissiez pas là oui
il va pas donner pour la croix rouge
il va donner un juste pas très bien
comment ça va ce club olympiacos là et
bien ils sont ils sont premiers pour le
moment il ya encore deux matches la vie
à athènes ça vous plaît super ah oui
c'est assez bon à jeter des brebis la
[ __ ] ans adriana l'epad qu'elle espère
que je connaissais quand même kalinic
ta'qali nict non ça ça veut dire bonne
nuit
non ça veut dire je nique ta mère
la révue commencez à vous y faire dans
sérieux non non parce qu'en fait 1
je vois pas trop l'intérêt des gens il
me parle très bien anglais nous je ne
sais pas combien de temps on va rester à
arsenal parce que dans deux mois et son
bar oui c'est ça que ça veut dire
f calysto poli oui ça veut dire ça mais
non merci
c'est pour dire pour dire non ils font
comme ça s'est vu alors là bas en grèce
comme vous sortez pas beaucoup ensemble
les rumeurs vont bon train adriana vous
le savez un lait les rumeurs vont bon
train les paparazzi la presse à scandale
s'en donnent à coeur joie
mais heureusement on peut parler à l'un
de ses patrons et alors on dit les c'est
terrible ce qu'on raconte dans la presse
à scandale là bas et on dit que
christian là bas mission vous bat la
presse à scandale bac direction c'est
pas ça le truc c'est christian là bas
elle est ici
ces gens du ca où ils ont dix tonnes en
dix à la presse à scandales a dit que
christian vous battez enfin qui me bat
d'après ils sont 10 km ou sexuelles au
moins sept chats l'annoncé non ça j'y
crois pas une seconde
en revanche en revanche ils ont dit
qu'ils avaient une petite copine ça oui
un petit nom mais quand mes petits
copains à moi ont dit qu'ils allaient
divorcer secrètement on dit que j'ai de
belles gosses ont dit vous partez pas
ensemble en vacances voilà à quoi la
presse à scandale s'en donnent à coeur
joie sans jamais comme c'est toujours le
cas
vous demandez à vous d'authentifier ces
propos c'est toujours pareil quoi ouais
mais maintenant ça ne touche plus jamais
été victime bout de la presse à scandale
jamais non non non j'ai entendu dire que
muriel juge avant de dire que muriel
avait une aventure
enfin le lendemain non non vous non plus
non mais c'est quand on veut dans la
fusion de show oui oui oui on a jamais
mais jamais rien lu sur vous mais
bascule à la presse et prévenu que
là-bas venir ouais tout
ouais enfin c'est ça c'est ça certaine
presse maison ça va avec muriel très
bercy
bien alors donc voilà effectivement il
ya beaucoup de problèmes alors nous on
se demande un peu évidemment puisqu'on
est loin donc on se demande déjà avant
c'était ma famille famille de questions
ici sans qui était beaucoup
alors justement donc pour savoir où vous
en êtes avec christian on va voir si
vous connaissez un petit peu le football
aura offert une interview télé foot
donc c'est pas compliqué c'est
vérification des connaissances pour
répondre 6 si adriana n'y arrive pas
c'est quoi un hors jeu
voilà je savais que vous avez des
montres
c'est quoi je sais mais c'est difficile
à expliquer voilà vous savez je me suis
gérant marc bien sûr
ouais festival a aussi oui c'est quand
un joueur tape dans le ballon à un
endroit du terrain où il n'est pas censé
le faire c'est bien c'est pas mal et
c'est vraiment bon c'est quand il n'y a
pas au moins un défenseur entre
l'attaquant et le gardien voilà il ya
hors jeu vous auriez pu le ca je vais
avoir des doutes je vais faire pas
quoique n'est pas souvent que les 142
qu'est-ce que dites-moi ce que c'est le
coup du chapeau le hat trick qua non
c'est non c'est pas parce que non non
c'est quand ils marquent trois buts dans
le même match
ça ça varie avec fait si on n'est pas
habitué c'est pas un triplé alors c'est
quoi d'avoir la barre transversale
à temps
vous connaissez à l'ena vous connaissez
excuser un petit pont petit pont le
petit pont il le fait et sur le petit
pont le petit pont c'est faire passer le
ballon entre les jambes du joueur quand
on est à jamais un petit peu aidé des
personnes venaient pas beaucoup qui sont
pas non non c'était aussi on les garde
le match en question et s'énerve
si je demande quelque chose genre je
suis très sévère manière c'est cela qui
frappe c'est normal qui s'énerve parce
que lui et en même temps il ajouté
mais depuis
ben c'est pas la peine de lui demander à
wichita dernière question là est ce que
vous savez on va voir si vous connaissez
le ballon est ce que vous savez adriana
karembeu ou d'oie et arbitres il suivit
le ballon oui les bamanan à qu'est ce
qu'il va faire les arbitres
aux chiottes travers 1 1
m
billy je vais vous laisser filer parce
que demain vous montez les marches pour
la première fois toile à ludivine
sagnier
puis je suis libre
et maintenant
voici quincy jones sort
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
en soirée ici c'est heureux de vous
avoir avec nous ce soir
alors je crois que la meilleure façon de
présenter quincy jones et à ceux qui ne
connaissent pas c'est ça didier
on
oh
oui
mais bon
à
[Musique]
or
et
j'essaie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
quincy jones
oui c'est jones
cher
[Applaudissements]
si ce morceau
100 millions
[Applaudissements]
ouais voilà quincy jones arrange écrit
produit tous ses morceaux et bien
d'autres 100 millions d'albums vendus
quincy jones ou comment un gamin des
faubourgs les plus misérables de chicago
est devenu l'un des plus grand
compositeur arrangeur producteur de
musique au monde
[Musique]
voilà quincy par quincy jones
ça c'est pas de bus comme ça c'est un
barrière
en attendant les moulins qui est
magnifique et il dit c'est un bonheur de
rencontrer queen sinon oui enfin on se
connaît depuis de neutre et c'est queen
sim a connu tout petits et tout-petits
comme quincy travailler ses casques et
oui chez barclays la première fois que
je rencontre et quincy lui sont souvent
revient bien mais ces marins c'est quand
j'ai des marques le groupe et
chaussettes noires et il enregistrait la
musique du film avec paul newman
il y avait amstrong duke ellington mais
c'était monsieur déjà qui faisait les
rayons plus est dit et moi même johnny
hallyday nous avons été les témoins de 5
du mariage de sas est sûre c'est sûr
les mariages de liberté ça donne des
occasions de ceux de se retrouver ca
fait plaisir
christine de voir si c'est un monument
vraiment alors il a écrit un bouquin qui
commence très mal
ça commence dans les hivers des du
kentucky
il fait très froid vous dites un froid
mordant impression de jolis de
l'intérieur impression qu'on aura plus
jamais chaud et vous êtes tellement
pauvre quand vous êtes enfant quincy
jones que vous mangez des rats free
c'est à dire que votre grand mère vous
cuisine plutôt bien d'ailleurs der
afrique
heureusement que ça s'est passé comme ça
que je suis passé de la pauvreté disons
à l'essence et au contraire c'est mieux
que l'averse que vous avez raison c'est
vrai engouement jarrier des renfree en
ce moment ça devrait quand même beaucoup
plus chiant alors votre mère est malade
ça a été vraiment un problème vraiment
pour vous on le voit en lisant le
bouquin toute votre vie vous avez vécu
avec ce poids elle s'en va un jour on
vous dit qu'elle reviendra bientôt
le problème c'est que c'est bientôt
allait durer des années et il ya une
scène extraordinaire dans votre bouquin
c'est le jour où les infirmiers l'emmène
il lui met une camisole de force
elle hurle elle se débat et l'emmène
quand même alors vous raconter aussi la
visite à l'asile ou votre mère est
enfermé alors au départ elle sourit vous
dit quand on arrive elle sourit avec son
son beau sourire comme quand elle nous
brosser les cheveux ou quand elles nous
mettait nos culottes courtes et avant
son visage change complètement
et elle se met très en colère et elle
part dans dans la rage et pour un enfant
ça doit être terrible
sauf que depuis j'ai appris que bon avec
cette démence précoce elle aurait pu
être sauvé si on lui avait donné un peu
plus de vitamines b c'est tout ce qu'il
leur tout ce qu'il aurait fallu c'est
dans les années 30 et 40 on ne savait
pas tout ça alors tout au long de votre
vivre comme ça il ya des réapparitions
de votre mère un jour en 61 vous êtes à
new york dans un club qui s'appelle le
beurre blanc qui est vraiment la mecque
la mecque du jazz
elle débarque et quand vous entendez
dans l'escalier vous dites il va arriver
elle va faire un scandale est alors un
jour vous avez quand même compris que
les problèmes que vous aviez eu par la
suite avec les femmes
votre côté donjon en votre donjuanisme
exacerbée quincy jones était dû au
problème
finalement vous aviez connu dans la
relation et votre mère la ville de paris
mais un peu été arrêtés ces problèmes
alors après le départ de votre mère
votre père vous emmène chez votre
grand-mère et là vous connaissez le vrai
racisme c'est à dire qu'à l'époque les
états unis avaient encore y en a
toujours mais à l'époque avait un vrai
gros racisme humiliation à l'école on
vous demandait à vous à votre frère
d'enlever vos chaussures pour vous
gratter là la crasse sous les pieds
alors finalement dans votre père revient
à vous chercher chez votre grand mère
vous partez au sud de chicago dans un
quartier qui est tellement violent qu'on
l'appelle le sou de sang il ya des
bagarres il ya des vols et les gangsters
et vous devenez un petit truand c'est à
dire vous apprenez à vous à vous
défendre
quincy jones et un jour voilà vous
apprenez que dans la seule défaite de
l'endroit il ya de la nourriture qui est
stockée
ça s'appelle l'arsenal vous entrez la
nuit par effraction et vous trouvez une
glacière dans laquelle il y a des tartes
au citron meringuée donc ils rendent
comme ça la nuit il là vous voyez un
vieux piano qui est là sur une sur une
estrade vous le regardez vous commencé à
pianoter d'un doigt et vous trouvez à ce
moment là la paix pour la première fois
vous savez au moment où vous entendez
cette note que quelques vous générez en
tapant sur le piano vous savez que c'est
votre destin blitz cette phrase
extraordinaire chaque note comblé mais
vide intérieur j'avais trouvé en une
seconde une nouvelle mère la musique de
ce bateau tape membres vient
effectivement ce moment m'a
littéralement sauvé la vie et bien moi
pour moi j'ai eu cette nouvelle merde la
musique a été cette mère bienveillante
qui va connais tout l'amour que
j'attendais et qui m'a rendu l'âme
auquel je tenais cette chance ensuite
vous installé à seattle vous rencontrez
raid charles cirque à l'époque ça tombe
sur wright charles ray charles avait 16
ans vous vous avez 14 ans et c'est pour
vous c'est un modèle wright charles
c'est à dire que malgré sa cécité
il se comportait comme un petit homme il
était tout à fait indépendant malgré son
jeune âge 16 ans et vous vous commencez
à le prendre comme modèle
en effet un modèle parce que moi
j'habite encore ans la maison alors que
shahzad ait son propre appartement
il était propriétaire de deux costumes
et de deux petites années alors c'était
fabuleux
il était parfaitement capable de faire
tout ce qu'ils voulaient pouvaient aller
au magasin tout seul traverser un bus
rouge rentrait chez lui on va faire ses
achats et les deux seulement où ils
étaient plus avancées comme lui ou s'il
vendeur rencontré une belle foule à
l'atlas où il faisait sombre le trader
qui pourrait traiter par les belles
femmes d'ailleurs aujourd'hui et encore
mon ami le plus proche bon alors là
c'est sur le piano de richard lorsque
vous travaillez le premier morceau que
que vous avez écrit dans votre vie et là
il ya un épisode c'est assez triste
c'est qu'un jour vous rencontrez lie en
allant tonnes et et vous lui demandez de
faire partie de son orchestre il vous
accepte dans leur cas est vachement
content de cette très jeune et la femme
de la lionel hampton arrivée et commence
à l'engueuler en disant mais qu'est ce
que c'est ce môme que tu as appris dans
leur quête tu vois bien qu'il est trop
jeune il faut qu'il aille finir ses
études avant de faire partie de l'
orchestre et vous vous êtes dans le bus
ah si vous êtes prêts à partir en
tournée avec lionel hampton et sa femme
ou fait descendre du bus c'est terrible
et ce n'est que trois ans plus tard
qu'effectivement j'ai intégré le groupe
mais enfin tout est bien qui finit bien
tout est bien qui finit bien mais vous
dites sur le moment j'ai cru mourir quoi
c'était terrible parce que c'était d'un
seul coup
tous vos rêves qui est qu'ils
s'enfuyaient alors ensuite sur les
conseils de lalo schifrin que vous
rencontrez à buenos aires en même temps
que astor piazzolla d'ailleurs vous
venez en france pour travailler avec
nadia boulanger pas si vous connaissez
nadia boulanger mais c'était un
professeur de composition qui était ami
avec ravel avec stravinsky avec
stravinsky a été un peu plus qu'à me l a
eu d elle a fait des galipettes un peu
avec stravinsky non je ne sais pas
j'étais pas là pour la taquiner un peu à
ce sujet faute parce que mais on m'a
appris des choses dont je me souviens
encore et toujours des choses que je
n'ai compris que vaches temps après les
avoir entendues prince est probablement
la personne n'en doutait sur le plan
musical et le pis a fait en somme a été
et je la présente et je lui ai présenté
avec elle au sujet de stravinsky ne sais
pas si c'est vrai tout c'est incroyable
c'est cette vieille bonne vanne qui
était un ami de stravinsky de ravel qui
avait eu gamme stein comme comme élève
qui avait refusé gershwin
elle vous a tout appris à vous et elle
vous a appris surtout que finalement il
n'y avait pas de vraies créations sont
contraintes c'est à dire qu'on ne
pouvait créer qu'à l'intérieur d'un
cadre défini sinon c'était pas possible
des contraintes de vous n'a pas de
contrainte
alors on ne peut pas avoir des libertés
moi je trouvais ça un peu difficile
parce que j'avais joué dans des boîtes
de nuit thiam a peur absolument
hip hop mais également du réseau de man
blues en fin de tout lui aucune surface
mais c'est elle qui était un véritable
géant la musique elle m'a dit une chose
que je ne dirai jamais elle a dit que la
musique une personne ne peut pas être
plus ou moins que ce que vaut cette
personne n'entre en qu'être humain et ça
c'est une bonne raison d'essayer
d'améliorer sa propre vie en tant
qu'être humain alors en 57 vous êtes de
nouveau en france engagé donc par nicole
barclays comme directeur musical
arrangeur chef d'orchestre et vous
pouvez enfin écrire des arrangements
pour cordes
parce que les états unis allaient
de toute façon les noirs n'avaient pas
le droit d'écrire des arrangements pour
cordes
c'est vrai on était limité au queen's
donc j'ai appris énormément de choses
grâce à débarquer il m'a pris tout
simplement la musique d'ailleurs
également la cuisine battu voilà donc
avec une barque les bouder il découvre
la jet set la côte d'azur d'un seul coup
évidemment pour vous c'est c'est énorme
alors ensuite vous raconter en 74 un
truc terrible une un anévrisme ça qui
forment donc c'est l'artère principale
qui emmène le sang dans l'hémisphère
droit du cerveau qui s'est rompu c'est
l'équivalent de 16 attaques et vous
devez subir à ce moment là une opération
du cerveau
v une chance sur 100 de vous en sortir
et de toute façon même si vous en sortez
vous avez énormément de risque d'être
paralysée d'être aveugle et alors vous
raconter cette scène extraordinaire
c'est quand on vous emmène pour vous
pour vous opérer pour vous passer sur le
billard
vous avez le crâne rasé et et vos
cheveux sont mis dans un petit sac en
plastique accrochée à la civière
au cas où vous mourrez comme ça on
pourra vous remettre les cheveux pour
l'enterrement mais ce qui était sympa
c'est que si vous survivez à cette
opération servira bien parce que
malheureusement vous avez un deuxième
année liszt et dans deux mois vous y
repasser et honduras d'une couleur là
c'est ça qui me faisait trop tôt pour
dire que la v2 chanson une chance sur
deux de 2002 ressortir plutôt qu'une
chance sur mille et alors ça va
maintenant
le seul problème c'est que je suis
obligé de faire un régime et en france
c'est pas un régime sans fil au moins
aux annonces à n'ont jamais j'ai compris
à ce moment là que en avait 25 mille
jour sur terre pour tout faire avec
il fallait en profiter si on regarde
regarde sa vie comme ça disons que là
trente mille 30 millions jusqu'à la dose
de 80 ans on dort pendant dix mille le
jour on travaille dix mille jouets des
dix autres me jours c'est pour jouer
pour s'amuser pour tout ce qu'on veut et
donc si on divise sa vie comme ça entre
le sommet le travail et le reste voici
ce qu'il vous reste alors c'est ce que
je vous le dis il faut vivre chaque jour
comme si c'était le dernier jour de
votre vie vous avez bien raison
[Applaudissements]
alors voilà le livre raconte tous les
artistes pour lesquels vous avez
travaillé quincy évidemment il ya dinah
washington frank sinatra que vous
rencontrez à monaco et qui quelques
années plus tard vous rappelle alors
vous pensez qu'il vous a oublié
ils vous rappellent pour que vous
produisiez son son disque et puis
michael jackson michael jackson avec qui
vous avez fait off the wall
vous avez fait thriller et vous avez
fait bad ensemble thriller 40 millions
d'albums bat seulement 22 oui c'est vrai
c'est un peu un flop mais c'est pas tout
à fait jackson de 6 à découvir est tout
à fait comme flop tout à fait oui qu'est
ce que vous pensez ce qui est devenu
aujourd'hui bien je pense que disons
qu'il allait passer de du fantasme à la
réalité et dix personnes
mais je crois que on peut pas trop lui
chez lapierre je crois que ce qui m'est
arrivé depuis l'âge de 5 ans tous tout
ce qui lui est arrivé a été multiplié
par mille parce que c'est probablement
l'artiste du célèbre en tout cas sur le
fond musical c'était vraiment la star
des stars et c'est dur à gérer si on n'a
pas vraiment ils ont la tête sur les
épaules ce n'a pas un centre spirituel
il faut la spiritualité en or en soi
pour pouvoir garder la tête froide ce
qu'on fait en général en ce cas là dire
que c'est l'énergie qui vous fait monter
bien sûr inconsciemment cette même
énergie foot rennes vers le bas sans
qu'on s'en soit conscient ça j'ai vu ça
des milliers de fois et j'espère que ça
vous arrive à pas et 10 et vous avez
senti à un moment vous ça vous est
arrivé ça cesse de vertige comme ça de
vous dire je me sens mieux je contrôle
plus je l'installé à canon je suis si un
jour je vend 40 millions d'albums
peut-être ouais mais donc j'ai le temps
bien alors vous vous avez des problèmes
aussi psychologique certain moment vous
produisez vous produisez la couleur
pourpre avec steven spielberg et la
suite de ça vous êtes victime quincy
d'une dépression nerveuse
autres moments difficiles aussi
quand votre fille qui dada vie avec
tupac et que tupac et assassiné aussi
très oui il était fiancé se marier quand
il s'est fait assassiner
il s'était querellé avec un autre gang
avec le scrutin était censé être assise
à côté de lui dans la voiture où il
s'est fait assassiner heureusement bas
il n'était pas allé chercher la fin
parce qu'elle serait morte elle aussi 25
c'est incroyable et quelques mois plus
tard big notorious était assassiné aussi
dans tout ce groupe de rappeurs de los
angeles
vous avez été parmi les premiers à
prédire le succès du rap et l'importance
du rap
moi je me souviens on s'est vus pour la
première fois dans une émission en 1989
qui s'appelait lunettes noires pour
nuits blanches et c'est vrai et vous
m'avez dit ben oui le rap c'est comme le
jazz c'est comme le rock ça va tout
révolutionner en été en 89 bon ça
commençait à peine et vous aviez raison
parce qu'aujourd'hui ça a été une espèce
de déferlante mondiale oui j'ai eu le
sentiment parce que j'ai suivi les tout
débuts du rap
il y avait elle elle coule jake avec
quinze ans je me rappelle qu'on m'a dit
une fois attendus dans les bureaux de m
il a du mal à demander qu'est ce que
pensent les musiciens de nous et je lui
dis mais vous êtes au fait pas
exactement des musiciens des chanteurs
vous êtes dans la tradition orale
africaine comme comme les compteurs de
bangui voilà alors donc oui jean jones
aujourd'hui vous avez 70 ans et vous
êtes en train d'écrire votre première
comédie musicale consacrée à ces me
davis junior
vous avez bien connu vous dit la
retraite c'est s'asseoir et attendre la
mort de ta près de prendre votre
retraite donc certainement pas on parle
beaucoup de retraite en france à ce
moment puisque pas non mais il faut
continuer à rester vivant dans l'esprit
pour que le corps reste jamais aussi
vrai dit
moi
je vais vous faire une interview vous
trouvez ça normal vous quincy jones est
ce que vous trouvez normal que vous ne
soyez pas par an avec indiana jones
c'est dire que nous sommes cousins
éloignés quand même harrison ford en
fait c'est un j'appelle jones est ce que
vous trouvez normal que le plus grand
rappeur du monde
eminem soit blanc le plus grand rappeur
du monde et plan le meilleur golfeur
experts et les soeurs williams et des
tennis tennis woman sont noirs et de six
le plus grand basketteur chinois
ce sont les suisses pour l'america's cup
et l'allemagne ne veut pas un hacker
est ce que vous trouvez normal quincy
jones qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde se
foutent de la gueule de michael jackson
s'était pas normal enfin bon moi je prie
pour michael vraiment je prie pour lui
parce qu'il a beaucoup de très bonnes
choses en lui
j'espère qu'ils s'y retrouvera peut-être
que ça lui prendra du temps et il faut
qu'il se repose un peu
est ce que vous trouvez normal que
beaucoup de gens aux états unis croient
qu elvis presley est toujours vivant moi
je crois bien qu'il soit vivant et je
suis pas un grand fan d'elvis précis
d'ailleurs est ce que vous trouvez
normal quincy jones concon bombe devant
un film porno et qu'on est pas mal
devant un film d'action
ce qui montre un peu la bizarrerie du
monde tout tout est à l'envers
c'est le monde à l'envers est ce que
vous trouvez normal que les artistes
américains qui sont contre la guerre
d'irak soit inscrit sur une liste noire
je crois qu'effectivement c'est une
contradiction la démocratie chacun
devrait avoir le droit à ses propres
opinions aussi sale principes de la
démocratie
chacun devrait être libre de ses
opinions même si ces opinions sont dans
l'opposition je crois pas que ce soit
juste les deux les black listé des mecs
aux listes noires est ce que vous
trouvez normal quincy jones que je vous
pose toutes ces questions à la con non
non
c'est sympa luigi jones corp insidious
c'est sur leur emballage messieurs
bien bas quincy et vie je vais vous
laisser filer tous les deux à mon avis
vont boire des coups jusqu'à 8 heures du
matin
messi messi mais c'est très bien au
revoir à tous les bébés archi d'achat
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant et maintenant
à
[Applaudissements]
c
28 aura
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
soir bonsoir kelly aventura dont vous
êtes la fille de lino ventura et vous
publié chez robert laffont un livre qui
s'appelle lino tout simplement
[Musique]
voilà lino tout simplement souvenirs
d'enfance et recettes de famille alors
c'était à la fois une lettre à votre
père lino ventura pour lui dire qu'il
vous manque et puis qu'il vous manque
lui et sa cuisine
vous dites que de souvenirs d'avec mon
père qui n'est pas une vague odeur de
persillade d'huile d'olive et de tomates
fraîches
c'est vrai c'est assez tête ou pas pas
ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors à vous parler de votre père vous
parlez de vous parler de votre grand
mère grand mère ça se dit non non en
italien non non non oui mais voilà
s'appelait louis sam et bloup les nanas
alors avec elle lui
lino parlait toujours italien est avec
vous jamais en fait n'ont jamais ça
c'est une chose que j'ai jamais
comprises mais peut-être que j'ai un peu
analysé
c'est à dire que il voulait vraiment lui
qui avait tellement souffert de
l'intégration je pense qu il voulait que
nous on soit vraiment intégré donc pas
d'italien oui un peu comme un peu comme
la mère de france d'enracinement
c'est marrant tout à fait ça cette
volonté comme ça d'intégration c'est
moins le cas maintenant
alors elle avait sa langue à elle cette
nonne a que comment elle disait
buckingham le palais de buckingham
elle c'est lé palais des boues jindam
voilà alors c'était oui évidemment
illégal j'espère du film de reagan 6°
jester voilà alors était très possessive
1 et chaque fois que votre père lino
ventura partait faire un film de
gangsters
elle me met nue c'est pas une crise une
maladie très grave quoi ah oui c'était
toujours terriblement pathétique c'est
la commedia dell'arte à la maison
soit ça à l'aide d'un simple migraine à
la crise cardiaque et c'était toujours
quelque chose de terrible parce que papa
y croyez vraiment à les deux trucs
qu'elle supportait pas donc c'était
quand il faisait des films de gangsters
et puis quand il prenait l'avion aussi à
supporter alors elle était d'une
positivité je dirais naturel quand on
connaît ses origines parmesane et puis
aussi le fait que son mari donc le père
de lino les ai abandonnés très jeune oui
c'est vrai que ça a été une épreuve très
très difficile et papa l'a très mal vécu
enfin il ne m'en a jamais parlé mais je
crois qu'ils en avions dû beaucoup
beaucoup à cet homme est en fait il est
arrivé en france à 7 ans avec sa mère il
a commencé à travailler à cet accident
il a eu cet accident deux triporteurs à
9 ans et
comme la police française comme il
n'avait pas de papiers l'accompagnèrent
en italie et là il a été levé par clélia
ouais alors de ces épreuves
lino ventura tirera sa morale et deux
maîtres mots qui sont dignité et respect
alors il était incroyable c'est une
aventure à parce qu'il était comme ça
quoi c'est à dire que par exemple il
fait la cuisine on va en parler
il laissait jamais une cuisine salle
quoi il nettoyait la cuisine quand il
avait fini ou continuer dans un hôtel il
nettoyait la baignoire avant de partir
complètement ça c'était des principes
qu'ils avaient
jamais il aurait danger assure c'est
très violent alors vous raconter tous
ses traits c'est très intéressant parce
que c'est vu vraiment de l'oeil delà de
la petite fille quoi donc
par exemple vous raconterez quand vous
habitiez au parc de montretout ce que
vous appelez la salle des tortures que
tous les gens qui venaient présenter des
scripts à lino ventura est passé dans ce
bureau et ils discutent et où il posait
des questions c'est insupportable pour
les scénaristes vont les réalisateurs
les producteurs et people man 2 pourquoi
il dit ça
non mais je comprends pas parce que
norbert sa dame raconte oui mais
pourquoi il dit ça parce que moi dans ma
petite tête de parmesan fond je
comprenne alors et discuter tout mais
quand il avait une fois qu'ils avaient
accepté quand il commençait à tourner
après il disait plus rien quoi il est
d'ailleurs tout le monde avait hâte
quand ils arrêtent et discuter non mais
c'est vrai ce que vous dites ça explique
très bien le personnage en vous raconter
les déjeuners avec demandant cette dans
cette maison alors vous vous étiez
obligés de faire tout paris en mobylette
pour les chercher les ingrédients ah oui
pour aller chercher jambon là le pain là
enfin bon tout était la viande railleur
c'était c'était peut-être un périple
et alors ils recevaient beaucoup de gens
et un soir vous surprenez une discussion
entre entre jacques brel et votre père
vous être la vôtre un petit peu caché et
brest via votre père en fin de compte
c'est quoi une femme pour toi et lino
répond c'est un homme qui pleure de
temps en temps et ça ça m'a beaucoup
marqué moi ça m'a en tant que femme je
n'y pas d'accord alors n'a le droit de
pleurer c'est vrai qu'on a tendance des
hommes et on a aussi alors vous raconter
les vacances au cap ferret dans cette
maison le crac d'or la pétanque il est
très mauvais joueur aulas un peu comme
ça j'aurais dû montrer qui c'est raoul
aux quatre coins de paris qu' on va le
retrouver et à pied par petits bouts
façon puis et puis alors les vacances
dans la maison d'anjou parce que pendant
la guerre ce que je savais pas c'est que
votre père est obligé de se cacher parce
qu'ils étaient italiens donc évidemment
les théories kafkaïen ouais parce qu'il
était recherché par la police française
il était recherché par les allemands il
était recherché par les italiens parce
qu'ils étaient déserts peur
il a fait tout un périple pour finir à
barra s'est passé en joue donc c'est là
et après la guerre il était là bas il a
racheté la maison il aura rangé et donc
vous raconter les vacances d'été là-bas
visite c'était très difficile d'éviter
la cuisine parce que le matin quand on
se lever pour aller à la piscine fallait
éviter la cuisine parce que lui tu es
déjà installés et réquisitionné toute la
famille pour faire les pour faire des
plats quoi un petit peu mais même si nos
réquisitions n'est pas si vous voulez on
était de toute façon réveiller parlons
et du couteau a forcément la grasse
matinée
arrivé le 20 alors la grande épreuve du
vin le vin était servi en carafe de 6
litres une espèce d'examen de passage
parce qu'il fallait être capable de
tenir la carafe de 6 litres à bout de
bras ouais et puis je peux vous dire que
c'était pas évident parce que vu les
têtes que j'ai vu
faire ça à une table et que 18 personnes
ce n'est pas évident quand même vous
regrettez de ne pas lui avoir plus
parler ah oui énormément
en tant que femme daisy liszt et s était
difficile de lui parler parce que
c'était un silencieux
oui c'était quelqu'un oui c'était pas
c'est ptet pas quelqu'un d'un abord
facile mais comme tous les pères je
crois vous et lui parler ce soir on va
faire l'interview
10dans gamine disons gamine t'aurais pas
voulu être la fille de gaza en moins non
il ya un acteur aujourd'hui qu'il fait
penser à moi aucun il paraît que tous
les jeunes connaissent les tontons
flingueurs parker ça te rend fier non
pas particulièrement
tu touches des sous sur le dvd qui sort
tout pas non mais sur le lino
[Applaudissements]
sur le linoléum clélia et didon gamine
tu m'en veux d'avoir appelé clélia
hannon jeu désolé j'étais bourré non il
a mis huit jours
j'étais pas inscrite dans le calendrier
ça existait pas oui alors il a dit bon
bah je reviendrai plus tard et ça s'est
passé
oui pendant cinq jours j'ai vu j'ai pas
eu de nom vient gamine est ce que tu
sais faire les pattes maintenant mais
comment ça j'en suis fier tu as peur de
ressembler en vieillissant non du tout
au contraire il ya des choses que tu
aurais même dire plein sur les hommes
sur la vie sur plein de questionnements
surtout pourquoi tu me parlais pas bas
parce que tu étais pas facile lisant
gamine se fait pas chier de devoir me
parlait à travers art dix ans j'aurais
adoré ma femme parle comme ça en est on
perd
les aventures à lino
tout simplement géant vers la formule 1
[Musique]
j'accueille maintenant tina arena
voilà pour tous ceux qui ne connaissent
pas team arena
didier
oui
et
moi
[Musique]
oh
tina arena bien la chanson sa tête
ce retour un peu et
un but un métier des feuilles
non
ou les
orlando exige l'équipe
[Musique]
le temps
ou non
tina arena jeu tout retour un peu exprès
vous êtes toujours un best-of enregistré
à l'olympia
ça s'est bien passé cet olympia j'adore
le mp 1 oui c'est génial la pierre parce
qu'on sent la présence comme ça à
l'empreinte de tous les grands artistes
qui ont chanté la avant semis les cours
c'est très cool c'est très cool et
australiennes
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
l'australienne qui grande blonde assez
marrant c'est ce str a dit harry rabbit
australienne mais vous dites d'ailleurs
tina arena c'est un avantage parce que
les journalistes font pas attention à 1
mais gaf et me demande pas mon avis sur
tous ces sites c'est une chose assez
s'écoule être quelque chose d'exotique
pour tout le monde
cc c'est comme ça c'est situés en
australie là bas était france et
exotique mais mais quand on est
australien qui est un pays des antipodes
quand on est ici on a l'impression de se
balader avec la la tête en bas et en
haut dans 91 c'est vous que cette
absence dern
c'est vous le contraire
en quoi est-ce que ça fait quand même si
elle va mal à la tête de de se promener
comme ça alors à l'envers non ça va pour
vous c'est pas mais c'est supportable
j'ai l'habitude maintenant un pour faire
pipi c'est pas facile j'ai donné le ton
était donné le conseil le conseil après
vous fait la peep ida corr l'avantagent
davantage quand on est à l'envers c'est
qu'on n'a pas les seins qui tombent en
même temps oui
[Applaudissements]
mais quand vous chantez aller plus haut
en fait ça les plus bas c'est drôle
physique est le seul avantage d'être
comme ça de ceux qui sont à l'envers de
nous laisse très peu plus des 69 avec
des français quoi cette cire
les bains jeu
rabat
sagnol pas
et si nos crânes savait ce qu'on va
faire maintenant ça va être terrible
vous savez que les lieux à ce qu'on va
faire enfin annonce aventuré à wittes
challenges de demain dimanche 18 mai ya
une marche pour la lutte contre la
leucémie le don de sang et de plaquettes
l'association laurette fugain absolue
marche à 14h30 qui part de la tour
montparnasse jusqu'aux champs de mars et
à 17h et un concert gratuit et que plein
plein plein de stars et faut vraiment y
aller quoi tu seras toi moi je serai
avec bigard rumba cou présentait un
grave
[Applaudissements]
devant basso blindtest maintenant et
donc j'appelle au platine puis parti
n'étant pas la partie fut parmi quoi
non
[Applaudissements]
ce soir
et
pour jouer avec nous j'appelle pascal
sellem et max
mes toiles à max mais max von le côté
parce que sinon cette équipe est
vraiment trop fort pour connaissez le
principe je veux l'interprète attention
blind test dit
[Applaudissements]
est ce que tout le monde est prêt vous
êtes prêts petit philippe alors
attention ce soir tu remplaces philippe
bouvard dit attention il faut faire
attention attention non
l'interview
t
ma points pour l'équipe de glycine akram
déjà je suis mme bravo ou marque a quoi
comme ça d'entrée équipes 1
bravo bravo à vous quand tu avoues bon
héros voulez du renfort la soummam ouais
ouais là lâche moi attention attention
petit pipi janot adrien théaux
en fait j'ai compris et non j'ai conduit
c'était un match chine arena contre
clélia ventura chasser les deux [ __ ]
qui vont s'affronter terriblement ce
soir attention petit fils
[Applaudissements]
esso
non pas
moi bien bien attention attention petit
but
à
ça donne quoi ameline alors lé score 2-2
d'accord ok c'est bon mais d'origine
italienne djiba tu devrais les koné
touché de chance à lemon way attention
attention petit philippe
[Musique]
équipe de rêve
[Applaudissements]
attention petit vie
alors là ça commence là ça commence à
la 4 points pour l'équipe de tina arena
et seulement trois points deux points
pour l'équipe de christine okrent
adressé par christie c'est embêtant
c'est embêtant
attention petit é
[Musique]
points var québec le 6 oct donc ça fait
4 3 le point bas l'équipe de christine
ockrent jusque vous avez soufflé quand
il a souffert ici ça va péter ça tient
ce jour sa salade ans on a été honnête
on n'a pas répété on perd le même à une
petite manon laurent je faisais tu perds
le point
attention petit philippe contient quatre
choix d'audi
ah la la
m
amusant mais
après mila
non
c'est qui ce qu a dit ça le pauvre là
[Applaudissements]
d'accord romina power était la fille de
tyrone power
elle était avec titi est un pionnier
romy n'a absolument pas joué comme il a
power
donc on est à combien on et 1,5 pour
l'équipe de tina
à trois points
sion maintenant toute façon c'est le
chacun pour sa gueule
donc on ne joue plus par équipe
maintenant c'est le chacun pour sa
gueule c'est le banco petit film
contient quatre fois je vais y arriver
la scène
c'est une femme
non
oh
là on l'a pas aussi libre exactement
bravo bravo tina arena
l'australie maintenant parce que c'est
ma main sous les chandelles
attention on passe super banco petit
philippe lundi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tout me ressemble à un moment ça qu'on
mesure j'ai dit à quoi votre chien et
l'a fait prisonnier avant toi voilà donc
bah jeannot après tina arena le super
banco est remporté par laurent ma vie
mais attention il ya le méga banques ou
[Applaudissements]
m
c'est dur très dur très très difficile
faty philippe
[Musique]
lee
i wanna be america
[Applaudissements]
je vous demande de vous arrêter
je vous demande de vous arrêter à ce
jour c'est énorme la sociale on est donc
tina arena l'on ma fille pascale s'élève
alors maintenant évidemment si un de ces
trois larrons porte
l'ultra bon coup évidemment ce sera une
sorte de demi dieu le demi déesse
attention petit philippe
[Musique]
c'est que cet abattage matinée
le chef d'orchestre
non
[Applaudissements]
c'est étonnant par l'émission qui donne
envie de venir à rome
en saut
a sion bauchau de ce corps reporter sans
frontières
halabja
ap
[Musique]
sunil boules de françois
michael eavis à liège
gentil le vote
et c'est le crâne
françois lussi
une omission pensait
quincy jones quincy valensi
faux adriana karembeu
[Musique]
wahou
la campagne être solidaire
aujourd'hui devant
à lorient 2 1 4
[Musique]
merci d arreter avec nous
plus simplement
france et recettes de famille
en l'air l'avons aussi
l'album s'appelle j'ai toujours là et le
single
mais chez les politiques
on retrouve un peu
là alors demain dimanche france 2
diffuse matrix
alors partir de 21,50 soudan
avec des lunettes noires
le premier matrix voilà
non cela
quant à mon époux la semaine prochaine
m
je vais
[Musique]
à
je ne sais pas
je l'aimé
[Musique]
comment
m
[Musique]
je n'ai
précédemment fait rien